un salut tout le monde on est dans le
studio sf la place pour faire des
podcasts en plus de faire notre podcast
on loue le studio pour toi pour vous qui
peut venir ici avec ton concept de
podcasts nicole et le pour toi s'occuper
que tout soit traité aux petits oignons
tout ce que tu as besoin de farm enfoncé
âme et effet si da soit discutée faire
don podcast peu importe c'est quoi ton
podcast nichols occupe de tout le reste
on en voit ça à presse à paris m
pitau après ça tu le mets sur you tube
tu le mets sur balles à d'autres une
source près des fêtes fait ce que tu es
avec trois modes comme tu veux il
t'appartient
tout ça avec la plus grande qualité si
vous voulez plus d'information sur les
modalités de location du studio sfr
écrivez nous à sans filtre podcast à
commercial gmail.com
la banque est restée comme une
production du f
[Musique]
bienvenue au sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'on veut que nos invités
date est super gentil avec moi doom
plantes
si vous cherchez une façon de nous
encourager abonnez-vous à notre pétri
jan berchmans une plateforme de sociaux
financement ou est-ce que vous pouvez
encourager aux créateurs préférés
nous on offre du contenu exclusif
ont-ils encore moins de filtres ou est
ce qu'après chaque podcast on discute
deux mois nicole derrière la console ou
est-ce qu'on discute du podcast convient
de faire on approfondit la réflexion
fait que s'ils voulaient avoir accès à
ce trois pièces pour moi aller voir ce
pétillant le lien dans la gestion du
podcast puis cette semaine
bic dit on reçoit kim gingras et kara
delville pour lui parler de diversité
corporelle dans le cadre de l'organisme
équilibre qui lance sa campagne
s'appelle 300 commentaires 2%
commentaire
pour justement sensibiliser les gens à
tête rayer cette habitude dans déjà
d'une digue en terre sur le poids des
gens surtout dans le contexte d'activité
physique on parle ici donc on sait que
l'activité physique des fois ça peut
être sujet à créer des situations qui
est qui qui qui créent des commentaires
sur le pwa pis c'est pas bon parce ça
peut avoir des réactions négatives sur
la personne qui le reçoit
on en parle en long et en large dans le
podcast puis même des commentaires
parfois positive qui se veulent qu'ils
veulent bien intentionné peut avoir un
effet pernicieux alors on va parler de
soi dans le podcast est super
intéressant kara et nutritionniste de
formation qui est vraiment super calé
dans ce sujet il était vraiment super
intéressante prime à l'expérience de
danseuses à promettre perspective pas
intéressante aussi sur le sujet moi
c'était une conversation quand même
assez personnelle parce que nous on est
quand même aussi d'un milieu de support
aux basques ont été élevés dans un
contexte où est ce que les commentaires
sur le poète est monnaie courante
il ya des mécanismes qu'on a tous à
déconstruire chacune et chacun puis on
espère que cette conversation va vous
permettre de faire ça en fait parce que
nous on est un cheminement perpétuel à
travers le podcast puis on espère que
vous l'êtes aussi donc commenter
commenté nous ce qui vous pend ce que
vous pensez de la discussion
partagez vos réflexions thom europe
maman jamais fait ce que voulait si vous
aimez vraiment personnes atteintes en
demande
mais ça fait que partager chéri par les
à vos amis et bons podcast auj
[Musique]
merci d'être là 4 nous a écrit faudrait
vous savez c'est drôle parce qu'il
dansait dans le fond je vous ai comme
mais j'avais posté à chanter parce que
ouais parce qu'on se connaît pour pour
ceux qui nous est commun de connaître la
dation qui est très mou je pense non
coréen a commencé comme en ont besoin
comme l a fait le jeu et je sais pas si
vous suivez moi c'est quelqu'un d'assez
à cevital compte à présent je pense
qu'on s'est croisé genre est toujours
après vraiment besoin c'est croiser un
drapeau ici
c'est comme un enfant qui m'accompagnent
dans cette campagne membres j'imagine ce
que dit qu'est ce que tu gens non ça ne
m'était haspop les deux jours après la
vente c'est cela la campagne en fait le
réseau sortir le le podcast dans dans
les dates de la campagne en fait fait
que parlons-en
parlons de ce fait que allez-y je vous
laisse la balle
quel est le con organise campagne c'est
quoi ça
je peux peut-être baisse un petit peu
trop puis à l'approché de la bouche ça
va être juste plus facile pour nicole
après latence nous on est un organisme à
but non lucratif qui t'appelle équilibre
donc je pense que l'année prochaine
avait déjà soir 30 ans quand je dis oui
qu'on ouvre à prévenir diminué
problématiques reliées à l'image
corporelle dans la population donc chic
et on a plein de différents projets
plein d'initiative auprès de toutes les
aides publiques si différents donc on a
des projets avec des éducatrices en
petite enfance autant avec les profs au
secondaire
autun
ce grand public on a tout sous peu un
projet qui dessinait à 10 personnes puis
une parmi les différentes initiatives
ont eu trois grandes campagnes de
sensibilisation confère chacun et donc
d'en faire ce qu'on voulait venir
discuter avec vous aujourd'hui qui est
la semaine ne passe sans commentaire
après son vol prix équilibre et la
journée internationale sans diète aussi
donc ça c'est des campagnes dans le fond
qui ont lieu à chaque année chacun
exactement les compagnies elles mais à
chaque campagne qui accompagne un petit
peu un angle une thématique différente
en convoi dont d'aborder ce sujet
différemment puis dont la semaine ne
passe sans commentaire c'est une
campagne à chacun qui vise à
sensibiliser la population à
l'omniprésence des commentaires en lien
avec le poids et l'apparence et les
conséquences de tout ces types de
commentaires le c'est sûr que en tant
qu' en tant qu'organisme nous on vise
vraiment beaucoup à a dit oui
sensibiliser les gens par rapport aux
conséquences mais aussi tu es vraiment
avoir des aspects positifs donc vraiment
de faire ressortir aussi plus le positif
de cette soirée les solutions exactement
les recommandations donc cette année la
campagne le 23 novembre et
lang de cette année c'est les
commentaires en contexte de pratique
d'activités physiques et sportives
donc c'est une campagne qui me tient
tout particulier est pas pour rien non
plus convaincu qu'on a choisi cette
thématique là en fait - et chez qui les
moi je suis chef de projet et ça peut
faire trois ans maintenant que déjà je
suis dit non on est à deux nous en tant
que chef de projet juste apporter à
travailler sur craint une thématique là
un projet différent on est une toute
petite équipe sapeurs des fois les gens
m'ont dit vous êtes juste suite de
travail vraiment très très passionnée
qui vit dans le vent mais j'ai travaillé
sur des projets passés sexuelle rester
notre structure
oui non pas de lutter contre l'excès
rythme visuel tout suspense avant
peut-être un petit peu ce qu'on va
parler que non non non pas toujours si
j'ai le choix d'être à eilat et puis
j'ai aussi je m'occupe aussi d'un projet
en lien avec l'activité physique qui ça
quand j'ai su qu'on avait ce projet leur
luge équilibre j'ai pleuré
j'étais trop contente pour moi c'était
une thématique qui viennent beaucoup
touché par notre bagage pied dans le
fond avant de travailler chez qui
livrent gt gt en prison clinique et donc
je faisais de la nôtre en sportive puis
je crois beaucoup aux troubles
alimentaires aussi tout est une pianiste
de formation
oui le savoir qu'ils attrapent après que
je vais plus de clean et donc je suis
moins été en quatre ans tout son nouveau
bilan puisse réorienter vraiment plus
par image corporelle puis blues la
gestion de projet ou si je retourne à
l'école puis oublié on avait eu reste
lisse d'un projet au niveau d'activité
physique qui s est sûre le fait capoter
il fait que ça fait à peu près deux ans
qu'on travaille là dessus puis en
essayant de voir comment ce qu'on
pouvait on a beaucoup travaillé avec les
profs d'éducation physique depuis deux
ans qui on voulait voir mais le comment
est-ce qu'on pourrait commencer à
sensibiliser plus tout le reste
ronde au niveau plus des intervenants ce
parfum loisirs les athlètes les jeunes
et sportif tout le monde qui oeuvrent
autour d'un codex de pratique
d'activités physiques et sportives puis
justement c'est l'autre la campagne mais
je me dis ça serait tellement
intéressant de que le sujet porte là
dessus on ne jamais aborder chez qui les
bat vent qui pour moi c'est une
thématique que je trouvais qu'ils
étaient vraiment transversale parce que
on peut
c'était au temps des commentaires que tu
vas faire un enfant un ado où que tu
sois au plus haut niveau de performance
commentaire on évite le pot en apparence
c'est toujours non qu'ils se pour moi
c'était intéressant du titre d'aborder
des thématiques là pour commencer à une
première sensibilisation est tout seul
donc j'arrive au bout de mon histoire et
la campagne porte sur cette thématique
le puits justement nouveau duo
on a notre super porte parole des kilos
qui marie et marie soleil dion puis
on voulait avait toujours épiée dans la
campagne comme comme commentaire à tous
les anime et je voulais juste aller
chercher une ambassadrice quelqu'un qui
pouvait porter la thématique avec avec
nous pendant la campagne et c'est là que
j'ai découvert que je ne rêve plus je
m'approche murs à ce courriel là je vois
là la thématique la mission à
sensibilisation contre pour les
conséquences côté commentaires physique
puisse être c'est un oui je sais que
nous attendons c'est vraiment et un
match parfait c'est en tant que danseuse
d'embarquer sur une scène où on taille
dans une audition parce que qu'est-ce
qu'on juge en premier si ton physique
pure honte et j'avais justement
mentionné dans le passé à tout cas ce
qui justement t'es même pas encore
commencé à danser puis on juge des
découpes c'est une ethnicité c'est la
longueur de tes cheveux peu importe
quand tu joues sur ce point oui ou un
non pour ta job et donc des revenus
m'appliquant qui m'ont approché moi
c'est comme acquis oui absolument je
pousse et ça je trouve ça vraiment
intéressant à tous les niveaux c'est pô
juste parce que je suis de ma carrière
mais que ça commence exact puis c'est en
ce moment je pense que dans les
dernières années on a pas on n'a jamais
autant parlé de des conséquences
potentielles des commentaires par
rapport au poil puis c'est aussi un
sujet qui est qui est important
d'aborder part importante décortiqué par
ce qui m'attend pour quelqu'un comme moi
avec le background sportif que j'ai
c'est vraiment très récent que j'ai eu
ce déclic le de faire c'est vrai que au
final tout ce qui dans ma vie était
normal par rapport à maintenant amateurs
de sport d'excellence que la navy
étaient juste jamais remis en question
où est ce que au final chaque fois qu'il
le pourra était connotée négativement
toutes les fois où est ce qu'on m'en
parlait ça fait pas si longtemps où s
qui le déclic s'est fait de farouches
guerriers vraiment quelque chose à
déconstruire complètement loupé je pense
que c'est d'autant plus important le
genre conversation qu'on va voir
aujourd'hui puis l'importance aussi au
delà de l'organisme la campagne parce
que c'est capital en fait oui absolument
c'est quelque chose qui y aucun doute
que des commentaires sur le portier ça
existe ça existe encore trop il faut s
car ce qu'on a
est-ce qu'on est quand même mesurer
l'impact soit démesurée
je peux parler et sur l'autre les
déchirent se tient à quel point mettons
les jeunes sont soit victime de
commentaires c'est quoi les impacts
négatifs que ça crie sur leur santé
mentale parce que l'egypte se est ce que
tu sais que tu es quand on regarde par
exemple les les adolescents en ce moment
au québec la plus haute et la plus
récente enquête nous montre que plus de
1 à 12 sur deux est insatisfaite son
corps tout autant un ado sur 12 -6 55%
de ses 57 % des filles puissent 54% et
garçons fait que on va aussi c'est qui
dit souvent on peut mettre là on peut
parler que l'insatisfaction corporelle
c'était plus une problématique de pays
hôte pour plein de raisons pourquoi il
ya des études qui ont plus été fait chez
les filles il manque de données gauche
et nos garçons mais je pense que ça va
commencer à se peut mais on voit que
c'est autant autant les filles que les
garçons qui on y boit plus de
l'intimidation des commentaires
c'est sûr que les commentaires ça va
avoir un impact sur plein d'aspects
notamment sur sa satisfaction corporelle
au niveau d'intimidation on a des
chercheurs au québec qui ont fait des
études ou est-ce qu'on voit que les six
nations par rapport au poids c'est le
poids étant laissées ça ça peut être le
facteur en font le buzz
mes doigts sales et les facteurs voit ce
qui est le plus le facteur sur lequel tu
t'appuies ouais c'est par rapport au
poids c'est sûr ça juste comme justin à
main levée en pensant à mon secondaire
puis à mon primaire c'est sûr que oui
c'est ce qui revient le plus ligne les
surnoms les les insultes cesser à tout
le temps connotation liés au pôle
toujours toujours quitter choisi dans
l'équipe en premier quoi que ce soit
c'est dans ces mêmes étudiants voix et
quatre au québec est vraiment au
québec.le qu'il y avait 90 % des jeunes
qui disent qu'ils ont déjà été témoins
d'un ami qui se fait intimider par
rapport à son poids
ça serait peut être entre façon je me
trompe pas qui aurait déjà reçu ce type
de danton d'intimidation la petite
regarde un peu les niveaux delà de la
satisfaction corporelles à travers le
tenter des loges de 2,3 à rentrer dedans
voit un enfant c'est qu'un corps qui
prend conscience qu'un corps
il peut déjà commencer à intégrer
dépressive des stigmas qui lui sont
inculquées d'enfants avec des jeux il
peut associer par exemple la grosseur à
quelque chose et je viens guinée et la
grosseur quelque chose qui m'avait ou
qui peut qu'écouter gars qui qui
pourront donc apprécier par quatre du
dès l'âge de 4 ans elle a déjà qu'on
peut commencer à nous mêmes et sfr est
très satisfait par ailleurs quatre ports
propres records de france testez stats
après 90 % des jeunes de 8 à 12 ans
selon une étude qui disaient qu'ils
videraient dé jeter qui considéraient
déjà contrôler leur poids que l'on ne
dise ados commencé plus de jeunes
chanteurs 2.77 encore donc de donner
assez préoccupante
oui comme sa maison ça fait penser
génial l'année passée je suis un cours
de danse puis tout petit je note est
même ses 7,8 à puis je fais un exercice
j'aime beaucoup pas de la confiance en
soi puis toutes ses piges je leur
demande de passer à un commentaire qui
se disent négativement des fois c'est
qu'est ce qu'ils pensent que qu'est ce
que tu trouves de poche en toi à outils
a dit qu on se parle de super après ça
qui menaçait une tournure de phrase au
positif et qui aimeraient partager sa
phrase là tout petit je pense qu'elle a
peut-être séance et c'est pas parce que
je suis tout petit que je peux capable
et puis ça m'est venu me chercher des
taux si jeunes et déjà penser de même
que t'es trop petit c'est peut-être des
commentaires je demande donc que ses 40
ans du diario t il plus petit par
rapport aux autres de tournage quoi que
ce soit là mais c'est vraiment le
chercher c'est ça commence jeune non
puis qu'est ce qui est halal je m'étais
la réponse est quand même évidente
malgré tout je pense que ce n'est pas
dans sa pose et parce que une fois qu'on
met le doigt sur le problème je pense
qu'on est plus capable de le voir depuis
le déconstruire mais qu'est ce qui est à
la source de ce cessez les images qu'on
se fait balancer ses c'est l'idée l'idée
que la société aude dû bosser tout ça
dans le fond c'est évidemment on est
comme on peut voir ça un petit peu
commun
on est ton centre d'un gros macro
système tellement notre milieu de vie
aussi souvent on peut quand on regarde
un peu ce modèle la société enfants
notre environnement autour de nous et
les médias tous contre les photos qu'on
peut voir les réseaux sociaux les
magazines et tous et c'est quand même
beau mais c'est vraiment plus du tout
les systèmes de valeurs qui sont mis en
place toutes tes tout qui autour de nous
une influence plus tu es directs ou
indirects dépendent à manquer dans le
milieu de vie aussi toutes les pertes et
des parents les enseignants les coaches
relie tout le monde autour de nous ici
ont une influence aussi plus directement
puis nous mêmes aussi lyon ont contribué
à ce aussi en tant que personne
perpétuer tout c'est sûr que nous dit là
c'est sûr que ça peut être d'avoir des
compétences à peut avoir des effets
négatifs mais la façon c'est que nous
voulons proposer que ton milieu de vie
et de la société
on peut aussi avoir un impact pour
stefan j'ai souvent les gens autour de
nous au tour des jeunes autour de nous
et ont un impact aussi équipe ait
beaucoup qui peut être très positif pour
faire en sorte que la situation s'est
très il ya énormément de facteurs qui
contribuent quand il veut a toussoté
qu'en pense juste à toute la
grossophobie et de la culture de dieppe
dans laquelle on baigne régulièrement
depuis des années qu'on est inculqué que
minceur égale beauté égal succès égal
performance
cc c'est sûr que ça finit par une bonne
main sur le wiki vraiment me qui mis de
l'avant et qui complètement pour
il ya aussi cette semaine de voir toutes
les photos qu'on voit les retouches qui
peuvent se faire très peur de ce convoi
qui nécessairement réel d'où
l'importance d'initiatives comme
équilibre comme des dominos troadec
différents 10 ans différentes
plateformes qui m'ont mettre de l'avant
des vrais corps dans le fond et dans
toute leur beauté naturelle et leur
diversité il ya vraiment un manque de
diversité corporelle au niveau de la
représentation
et quand m les personnes grosses
devaient être présentés puis je viens de
le dire que je vais le mentionner dans
le potager référé quand je parle des
personnes avec des plus gros corps je
vais dire personne drôle parce que
c'était un enfant qui s'est propagé au
bâtiment soit parce que notre pôle
exactement sur un terme qui me dit avant
lui paraît pas dans l'objectif de la
lutte contre la grosse c'est sur le très
important de mettre ces bases là pour
pour avoir le bon vocabulaire par ce qui
m'attend pour encore une fois kaka qu'on
veut aborder des sujets appelons
maintenant plus plus haut qu est-ce que
c'est plus de l'actuel tepic on veut
changer listings mais c'est difficile de
savoir quels mots bien pour ne pas
heurter personne l'incident dans toute
cette toute cette société changeantes le
sais bien que tu mentionnes c'est dans
ce contexte là aussi c'est je pense la
meilleure chose à faire aussi cessé de
le demander
le fait est formé de voir c'est quoi qui
en a pour qui ils l'étaient en personne
grosse peur encore à être quelque chose
qui ne sont pas à l'aise ça peut être
associé à beaucoup de trop mince et
bonne lecture aux tout ça ça peut être
dérangeant affecté je pense qu'il
fallait vraiment aller coûte
de tout le monde pour voir qu'est ce qui
les rend à l'annoncé dans les termes
utilisés définir dans ce sens que parce
que prévu d'affecter cette intervention
m étais un peu ils sont peu dans sauf un
petit délai aussi que justement tu es
supporter en équipe et j'ai raté c'est
beaucoup en construit société c'est la
façon c'est le minimum qu'on y adonner
n'en vaut acheter terme leur qu'on
essaie de construire dont on essaie de
reconstruire donc voilà parti s'il ya
tout seul autour de nous qui est très
très très très très candidement gillard
ans très exactement qu'on essaye de des
normales aubry je disais tranquillement
exactement puis de travail et je te
demande si nous on travaille autant de
public c'est à travers tous nos
différents projets parce qu'autant on
veut viser les jeunes directement les
gens directement qui est les gens qui
travaillent autour qui sont directement
tour 2e quand vous ce titre avec
l'industrie l'image comme essayer de
faire changer aussi les représentations
qu'on voit donc tout ce système là que
j'ai l'impression que c'est un balancier
qui qui si compliqué en crise a ramené
lobo c'est parce qu'il aime et on a
maintenant qu'on se dire qui est le
tueur mais tant qu'on parle de la
question des réseaux sociaux pour pour
commencer par celle là dessus ou est-ce
que l'hôtel omni présence d'une image
musclé tchèque tout les stéréotypes
qu'on qu'on peut y attacher puis quand
tu vois des personnes avec des corps
plus diversifiée qui s'exposent sur les
réseaux sociaux au même titre que de
quelqu'un qui répond à tous les codes
souvent ça va être avec beaucoup moins
de succès en termes de risques en termes
de following s'arrête avec beaucoup
moins de présence beaucoup moins de
traction fait comment est ce que on
balance sur l'autre bord c'est comme si
on réussit à faire que ça devient la
normalité c'est pour que
pour que justement un enfant qui
grandissent dans ce système là soit
capable de trouver la représentativité
de sa propre personne dans à parts
égales en fait sur toutes les plates
formes le terme et on comprend aussi les
magazines ticket le tutu qui a été
remplacé correctement par les socios ce
qui est vrai mais les magazines ils
l'ont fait mais en même temps quand un
diachylon on prend la diversité tu
regardes au final pis tu vraiment la
diversité tu sais comme c'est quelqu'un
de si peu plus gros mais qui répond
quand même à tous les codes physique le
tout les standards de beauté fait
comment est-ce que comment est ce qu'on
renverse
ce petit et c'est vraiment dans la dans
la représentation il faut qu'on
représente davantage de personnes de
tous les formatés dans le spectre de ce
qu est le format corporels en tout c'est
la diversité corporelle personnes
définition même inclus tous étaient
d'accord
donc en ce moment en effet autant sur
les réseaux sociaux dans le print tout
c'est encore une très très très petite
proportion de ce spectre le kiki qui
représentait je pense dans les dernières
années on commence là on voit pille on
commence à voir si je pense pour faire
du bruit
ces savants ses orientations là c'est
pour tous ceux qui nous écoutent en ce
moment à ce que peut avoir cette
conversation là la maison que ce soit
avec vos frères vos enfants c'est en
tant qu'enseignante aussi même chose
c'était quelque chose j'en parle
beaucoup dans mon programme de mentorat
parce que je sais que surtout preuve
dans sa relance à venir les affecter
directement c'est ce qu'ils vont se
jauger à chaque jour sur ce qu'ils font
le fait partie du métier mais je pense
ça c'est faire du bruit
c'est même moi je me suis trouvé à me
réajuster à pied en travaillant avec
cette campagne-là en préparant pour la
campagne appui justement parce que dans
mon mentor aux deux sessions j'encourage
mes films amy gough de sauver danseurs
sur les réseaux sociaux peloter je le
vois mémoire automatiquement j'aurais
envie de dire waouh t'es belle mais t'es
belle dans le gros centre bell mersen
bel team et là je dis non à plat je veux
dire c'est j'adore à quel point tu
travailles fort jugé j'applaudis des
efforts j'aime telle chose de toi j'ai
cherché leur qualité pitt est vraiment
misé
encouragées à voir qu'est ce qu'ils
peuvent qu'est-ce qu'ils of thé le plus
chez eux et non juste le physique mais
moati c'est quelque chose de gros dans
ma vie mais la cause qu'on en parle de
plus en plus je peux venir me corrigez
moi si c'est ça c'est intéressant ce que
tu faisais parce que des fois en fait
même un commentaire positif peut être
comme pernicieux l'enfance que je pense
que c'est une des cibles de la campagne
oui on attend beaucoup le jeu tomates et
puis s'il commentaires dans le type
d'activité physique mais toi de faire
des commentaires
tu es péjoratif sur la bonne personne
métier un commentaire aussi positif
s'affairent encore renforcée que perrin
perec temps perdu pour égale positif je
me suis longtemps il avait eu un débat
autour de ce parce que tu es chez ces
gens à del qui avait beaucoup de portes
et puis le porte une photo puis le tout
les commentaires c'est howard quel point
et demain belle dans la map que quelques
saillies fait bien avant sa perte de
pops et comme c'était commentaires
qu'ils veulent positifs sauf que le sous
texte de ce qu'est ce que ça crée chez
quelqu'un qui lit soeur chez qui ça
renforce que 12h06 négatif ça renforce
encore une fois qui est des pac eurêka
vérité encore qu'avant aux mondieux tc
on valorise on survalorise la minceur
comme étant est l'ultime objectif à
atteindre pour être acceptée pourrait
considérer boxer et et c'est fait oui en
effet été les commentaires autant
positif ôtant négatifs peuvent faire du
tort
bondues tort
donc il faut prendre conscience de tous
parce que j'ai l'impression que les gens
c'est tellement partout c'est tellement
tellement tellement présent malgré le
fait que les gens semblent d'accord oui
on sait que les commandes âge pour c'est
pas bon mais je pense que les gens
réalisent à quel point on peut essayer
compliments tout con con petit peu
importe ça se veut comme un sous quelle
forme
ok ça mais encore l'emphase sur la
banalisation est de l'apparence persiste
la révision des de cette perte de paul
fischer
peu importe ça peut être qu'aux actes
exactement contexte de pratique
d'activités physiques des commentaires
du genre awa et l air en forme tu perdu
du poids
ça arrive constamment toute cette file
station le petit temps parents justement
de 2,2 le code à domicile a été le 3 mai
diament t on si police qu'une personne
est en train de vie non non c'est vrai
ça va c'est sa perte de poids est celle
où commence assez fou de finale et quand
il est bien dans sa peau s'il a du sens
de la question tant qu une idée en
regardant juste l'image de quelqu'un en
aucun cas où est ce que tu peux évaluer
sa santé ne peut évaluer sa santé
physique et sa ronde et mental tu sais
pas ce qui est en train de se passer et
piétons et qui pour se permettre de
faire ce dont il faut prendre conscience
et de ce type de discours le de ce type
de commentaire là puisque partout
partout partout où tu es justement
tantôt qu'il parlait du nombre des
statuts de ce qu'on trouvera son futur
mais il ya des études qui ont démontré
aux etats-unis 60% des émissions
jeunesse
donc ils ne sont pas plus heureux pour
lui 60 % de ses émissions le avait des
situations des commentaires grosse pub
oui oui oui donc qui est petit et moi
j'y repense beaucoup je pense que tu es
je dire comme comme tu devais te tente
où on a tellement été dans un milieu où
est-ce que c'était tellement normaliser
la moins risquée
témoin j'ai beaucoup beaucoup souffert
d'être team je me suis mis à définir ma
valeur par mon apparence qui s'essaye
énormément de conséquence des réversions
dit encore aujourd'hui qui je pense pour
ce que j'ai dit demain ces sujets
humains tellement tellement à coeur mais
c'est super normalisée et puis le petit
quand j'ai commencé à travailler puis à
tout autant mais des mois dans toutes
ses démarches et de commencer à
travailler dans le milieu piché qualité
je regarde des anciennes émissions jon
garland des eaux des émissions préférées
le que j'ai dû coûter une vingtaine de
fois que je regarde ça maintenant
puisque et cd dans ses poumons en tant
que sales arrive régulièrement dans les
conversations que j'ai avec mes amis mes
amis j considère quand même sensibilisé
par le fait que tu aies georges mais ces
constats quand même qu'ils ont fait tout
en référence à la valorisation de dia
mister de monter des déchets c'est
vraiment s y mettre j'avais tellement
raison petit mais moi je suis coupable
s'il était ou pas dans mon quotidien
mais quand de ses réflexes lucky qui
sont ancrées loin en crise le dissident
mois les deux décédés
des affaires comme on arrive sur balles
et piscine peut on tout le monde se
passe t on seulement en ligne plos par
exemple c'est tout le monde voit un mais
toutes les autres se peser
j'essaie les filets c'est comme ok tu
vois le genre mois puis tu vois aussi la
réaction
la personne qui paraissent puisqu'il
voit se moquer d'eux les quais et là
c'est comme ça influence ton
entraînement qui s'en vient mais c'est
ça aussi le sport
le pourcentage en eau qui rend chez
quick qui est loin d'un mois puis on
s'entend que tout le monde qui passe par
ce métis fait juste ce recul est un
petit peu plus en plus qu'il n'ya même
pas l'aspect performance derrière c'est
comme comme tu disais tantôt on joue au
ballon chasseur juste pour te regarderai
où si ce qu'on a connu
c'est pas normal maillot au plus haut
niveau de l'élite le qui ne savent pas
comme ceux qui disaient tu disais tantôt
que tu es toi tu tues tu commencer
maintenant tiers a jusqu'ici de thioune
comment d'aborder ces thèmes le puits
est ce que tu as l'impression que ton
l'industrie l'industrie de la danse d'en
haut ça peut changer ou savoure changer
parce que tu es j'imagine que la
pression vient beaucoup de l'autre nous
en parlait la dernière est une espèce de
pression de physique constants puis
quelqu'un qui aspire à devenir danseur
professionnel qui travaille avec toi par
exemple dans ton problème entre eux kiki
le bruch à comprendre qui est finalement
son corps il peut être parfait pour
faire prévaloir petit puits puis qu'
aucune limitation est ce que tu penses
que ça peut traverser jusqu'à au niveau
professionnel mais dont moi je veux dire
oui t il rester positif puis je vois le
jeu commence à lancer revêtu du monde
comme les autres cherchaient des
danseuses de sa taille de satie donné
ses courbes sa forme après sa tenue
était d'aider chaud ça n'existe plus
mais comme glee que c'était traite et
diversifie en négligeant de danseurs qui
étaient engagées tout ça
la même janet jackson a battu lens a
déjà retourné à la fête comme un appel à
tous pour avoir des danseurs pour un
gala puis il ya vraiment de tout piste
est vraiment merveilleux c'est
magnifique c'est beau que je pense qu'on
en parle de plus en plus je me dis tu
sais moi je garde ça positif j'espère
que ça bosse à s'engager dans cette
direction lotis surtout après une année
comme on a eu tes avec côté diversifiée
et et je pense que le livre le monde on
fait du bourg et puis on écoute piège
est pas vraiment que ça va changer ces
musiques là comme si le déconstruire
c'est un métier depuis métro dans son
jeu mais une comédie est la même chose
que tu sais on recherche t on voit
quelle est ta photo g en premier lieu
c'est maintenant mon frère est fils
l'hémophilie casting tv pittis clos des
pages de casting puis à l alleud quelque
chose d'intéressant dans nos pages qui
ça reste sur le physique puis sur
l'image qui étaient jugés en premier
avant un total un autre coin de c'est
quand même parler sans ce métier dit
ouais c'est ça ce métier là ça car elle
aussi vraiment et c'est difficile je
pense que c'est pour ça dans le même
thème la thématique des commentaires
c'est quel genre de commentaires toi tu
t'offres aussi comment encore une fois
je pousse beaucoup seuls deux se
complimenter de ces mid de s'accepter
comme on est le bon comme le moins beau
quoi que ce soit comme ça on peut moins
checker rendu dans une carrière de même
hausse qu'on juge pour ton physique puis
mettons que tu parlais de du casting
il ya aussi la question oppose août
c'était la responsabilité du casting
directeur de déconstruire 6 dt de
déconstruire ccc préconçues puis
d'arriver avec un oeil ouvert sur la
diversité dans son secours de la page de
casting quand on sait que la ouais y'a
plus qu'à faire car il est en tout cas
maintenant quand il disait justement d
espèce de réflexe les médias qu'on
consomme les émissions qu'on consomme
soul s'est dit irrité par les démissions
de la jeunesse promet comme justement je
suis prêt que les missions de ces deux
références mais on est très faible
puis le père john lipsky ancien lecteur
qui dès missions que je constate et andy
ward sur plein d'affaires mettant le
traitement de mettons du passage de
keven tiki tiki tiki gosses mais ton
monte mais que que ses associés au fait
qui est un peu lent que le tea ils
voient des bergues pitt et c'est comme
quand les vieux stéréotypes tpiy qui au
québec il ya eu des bateaux un peu de
tout et la pub de maxime c'est quelque
chose qui est plus joli j'ai vu ce qui
est évidemment beaucoup au premier abord
je sais comment c'est drôle et anguilles
défensif mais je pense que c'est
l'époque antique construit cette c'est
parce que ça renforce encore une idée
que tu sais tu es peut-être un petit peu
nous noté peut-être un petit peu tu
aimes te manger plus que dix ans quelque
chose de chaud des caches en arrière
c'est pourtant de reconnaître même si le
festi positive sur l'esprit qui parce
que justement ça me renforcer encore une
fois des stéréotypes et des préjugés
mon prêt des personnes auprès des
personnes grotte puis tente on parlait
d'un manque de représentation façon
générale dans toutes les sphères par
rapport à la diversité corporelle là
le standard unique de beauté est encore
vraiment cette histoire conquis se
représenter mais quand les personnes
grosses sont représentés ils sont
souvent immédiate c'est souvent
négativement ça renforce tout plein de
préjugés on est non seulement une sous
représentation mais il y aussi une
souris présentation c5 tourer
présentation du positif exactement parce
que ses amis ont remportés dont plein de
fausses croyances et des stéréotypes
qu'on peut avoir qui allie personnes
dont il manque de volonté qui sont
moyens qui sont moins persévérants qui
sont plus petits ceux qui mangent plus
sous qu'ils entraînent moins et puis
c'est tout des choses qui viennent si à
force d'entendre ça part tout tu viens à
penser que que c'est que c'est vrai que
c'est juste implicit ou saumon pour
absolument pas juger quelqu'un deux
sites de ses habitudes de vie de sa
santé de tous par rapport à de quoi
qu'il s'agisse beaucoup renforcé avec la
team béton mais tant qu'on essaie de
voir dû pousser dans la trajectoire
qu'on aurait dû prendre en tant que
société puis tu me diras si je me trompe
ou non mais j'ai l'impression que dans
pêche donc un mois puis mettons nous on
était au secondaire ou même primaire de
fin 90 2000 y en avait une image de
corps qu'on voyait c'était ultra minces
cloud c'est justement à l'époque friends
n'est pas paru selten cette époque le
que je l'impression que le culte de sa
main l'armée s'arrêter à son apogée mais
tant pis tu l'impression qui mettons
dans les nouveaux shows discret dans les
nouvelles images qu'on voit les réseaux
sociaux salade eu du bon et du moins bon
métier n'empêche que moi quand je
regarde mes réseaux sociaux j'en vois
plus qu'avant t d une sphère encore est
ce que mes tempes y pense que l'impact
aujourd'hui chez les jeunes parce que
les jeunes sont plus préoccupés parce
que mettons nous à notre époque où ou
similaires ou supérieurs que d'après toi
première chose dans le sens l'été les
tendances convoi tic en parle partout
quand je parlais de plus d'un jeune sur
deux lointains sept mois ce
malheureusement ça ça lui augmenté
c'était super intéressant cette enquête
là parce que c'est une enquête qui a été
repris et même question où les mêmes des
méthodologies qui était la première
phase a été fait qu'elle souhaitait
avoir une première fois que moi j'en ai
pris connaissance de ce qui est de 2010
l'orfèvre 2016 2017 puis on voit qu'ils
étaient en cette courte période de temps
l'insatisfaction corporelle et jeunes
augmenté de 10%
instagram ont été créés en 2010 c'est
tellement multifactorielle yotel de
choses qui viennent et qui viennent
instruments sisters c'est quasiment
évident que c'est sur qui tu es ce
carillon un petit écriteau solution en
ce moment aussi et puis je parlais de
proust
après c'est que tu es avance qu on
voyait des émissions qu'on voyait les
magazines qu'on comprenne ça a été
exactement c'était des personnes qu'on
connaît c'est pas nécessairement qui
essaie on a comme une distance par
rapport avec oui le modèle unique de
beauté étaient étaient très présents ont
une culture store ça fait partie de
notre quotidien depuis la manière dont
on pense qu'on doit ressembler à ça
c'est sûr c'est évidemment ça fait
longtemps le coquet c'est un enjeu sur
les réseaux sociaux ce qui se passe ici
en ce moment chez q mais les personnes
quand on voit ces nos amis c'est des
personnes qu'on connaît ses effectifs
cette proximité lui aussi la capacité de
mettre des filtres de
on choisit toujours les photos on
choisit toujours un autre à notre
meilleur qui ça fait en sorte que ça
sorte
sinon selon sarah en force métier c'est
ça crée une espèce de d'image chi chi
chi minh pu réaliser tes pieds et est
déjà en partant quand tu regardes quand
on compare en convoi avec les autorités
guinéennes ont eu un tête-à-tête 6 5% de
la population qui ont un corps qui peut
naturellement ressembler à ce qu'on voit
dans les magazines sont une course en 5
% en sortie je me rappelle tout à fait
c'est quand que c'était un petit gars
était fait mais je serais curieuse de
savoir c'est quoi maintenant avec toutes
les télés on ne photos des vidéos ne
jamais en fait autant regardez consommer
des photos de cornes magasin qui disent
elles aussi c'est que par sa nature même
les réseaux sociaux ces images tête des
jeux qu'on est dans une société qui
valorise l'apparence pics et ça prend
déjà beaucoup trop parce qu'elle est et
c'est encore plus avant ce qu'on la
proportion des gens qui se mettaient à
saintes qui prenait des photos tu
portais ça c'était réservé à une espèce
de légende fonds sud en vie le thé
tandis que le ceram tout le monde
faisait pas dissoute et ne se prenait
pas photo pour les projets pour toutes
ses amies loi audric et le gros sport la
déplace maintenant à habarcq dans
l'avant midi quand on pense à ces délits
plus grands consommateurs les réseaux
sociaux si souvent les jeunes tc 6 10 et
14 ans je dois vulnérabilité ou est-ce
qu'on est plus vulnérable par rapport à
ces centres construit notre identité on
est entré on est beaucoup dans la
comparaison infectés on savait beaucoup
renforcé à quoi qu'on pense qu'on
devrait on devrait ressembler puis dans
le fond l'estiment estime de soi
cc c'est à l'adolescence limal l'image
corporelle c'est une des preuves et si
l'un le facteur le plus important pour
le sur l'estimé de soi etc et toutes les
répercussions que savoir si ici on parle
du positif parce qu'il se trouve
justement nous l'année passée c'était lé
deuxième anniversaire du prix qui lie le
prix global est tranquille et l'on
pensait tentatives des buts de kevin qui
va féliciter les entreprises mais les
initiatives québécoises qui met de
l'avant qui favorise l'acceptation de la
diversité corporelle est à son dixième
anniversaire est passé on avait tout
préparé un super bel atelier pour les
écoles cracovie pol pot était donné
c'est plate mais été on a regardé un peu
tes toute l'évolution dans les dix
dernières années puis j'ai dit si tu
pars belle dune tati qui se fait et y
sommes et plein de choses le qui fait en
sorte que 8 on commence à avoir plus de
diversité de différents modèles qui
t'ont veux présenter mes encore beaucoup
de travail à faire on commence on
s'avoue dans la bonne direction mais il
faut il faut continuer s'il n'ya
vraiment pas comment est ce que c'est
parce que maintenant la la
responsabilité mettant de la de de
montrer la diversité revient à certains
ou certaines preneurs de décision qui me
tombe je sois pour des des compagnies
qui font maintenant je pense à wasquehal
b trio qui a commencé à mettre beaucoup
beaucoup de diversité sur ses maillots
de bain cbe puis ça ça amène déjà mais
comment ce qu on n'évite de tomber un
peu dans le
dans le fameux token con con qu'on parle
souvent en termes de diversité que ce
soit diversité corporelle diversité
sexuelle diversité ethnique et comment
est-ce qu'on évite de tomber un token
l'exemple qu'on a récemment c'est si
julie occupation d'un buffer ok on veut
amener de la diversité mais est ce que
c'est la meilleure façon de le traiter
comment comment est ce qu'on fait ce
n'est pour exemple de diversité qu'on a
vu ici depuis un bout le titre de forme
comme un malaise un peu avec oman s'est
amené et puis commencer gérer c'est fake
comment est-ce qu'on évite ce une
période d'ajustement c'est certain si on
a beaucoup à faire beaucoup de chemin à
faire pour venir reconstruire
déconstruire et reconstruire ce que
s'est passé pendant plein été je pense
que c'est normal que je le sent aussi
des fois le tiche fait partie du casting
châssis tente d'un corps est alors que
ce soit placée comme qui ont aimé il
nous faut l'asia ce faire il faut la
black pig nouveau type c mais j'espère
que je te marque sessùn conversation
qu'ont à ce moment qu'on n'avait pas
avant ce à quoi on la pièce que dans
plusieurs dans quelques années vont être
rapidement possible lavaur il faut de
plus il faut c'est ça il faut que comme
tu dis il faut que ce soit plus que
juste été inquiété comment s'équiper
on met en même temps et il faut que ce
soit il faut que ça devienne
transversale à travers nos valeurs tu es
si tu dis que tu prends la diversité
corporelle une entreprise par exemple
mais qu'est que tu prends la diversité
corporelle crise aidant des valeurs mais
qui est par exemple ta ta ta ta
collection de vêtements vaut uniquement
jusqu'à la grande banque
donc c'est se faire ce qu'il faut qui
qui va falloir aller pied payer je pense
que c'est il faut pas mettre sur la
responsabilité individuelle c'est
vraiment aussi une question de réflexion
sociale que des nouveautés il faut
vraiment qu en tant que société qu'on
s'améliore dans un tout mais aussi été
en tant que consommateur un pouvoir
important
tu peux choisir les entreprises que tu
choisis de d'encourager puis de suivre
qui quittent de ces deux réseaux sociaux
ce match m'a témoigné une recommandation
condamne ce manque on va parler aux
jeunes c'est fait le nettoyage de vos
comptes à l'essuie des gens qui
encouragent l'acceptation de la
diversité corporelle qu'ils mettent de
l'avant l'acceptance l'acceptation soit
qui vont et qui vont en gestion qui font
sentir bien wasigny la d'instrumentistes
voix qui à travers ton finalement mené
toute sa famille notre comparer petits
pas bien qui sait prenons un peu de
recul peut-être un petit ménage à faire
factice et 50 ans de consommateurs ont
en eux de pouvoir qui s'était les
entreprises souvent ils vont évoluer
avec la demande qui fait qu'on a un
certain pouvoir là alvaro bautista
presto aussi avec avec qui avec ce qui
est arrivé avec avec aude était faut que
ça change on peut juste avoir tout le
temps
théo que cela cause d'avoir quelqu'un
d'encore plus gros pièce affaires à
faire et il faut absolument à l'it il
faut il faut plus qu'un faux il faut que
la version que ce qui s'est passé dans
ces situations là c'est quelqu'un voit
quelqu'un avec un corps qui lui
ressemble pas si cool puis là pendant
cinq semaines c'est jeu sam et lola
avait pas capables de ça renforce de
personnes qui tombent en amour avec elle
c'est comme celle ci il faut il faut en
même temps tu es oui ça ses poèmes il
faut pas avoir des faux pod faut pas lui
répond t il faut pas ajouter un gars
sont plus gros pour que juriste et sa
santé
je faisais partie
c'est juste comme on dirait qu'il
faudrait que comme pas dessus le nam et
il faut rajouter il faut qu'il y ait
plus de varier
je pense qu'il ya un travail si je
connais pas vraiment comment ça
fonctionne infecté top-12 on pourra vous
aider le maître et mettez au niveau du
casting d'aller chercher des gens ne
venaient pas si jobs se présente bien
c'est ce 2 août il faut aller chercher
et il faut trouver une façon d'aller
chercher plus plus grande variété de
deux corps de diversité culturelle et de
tout lors de divers vrd pour chercher
aussi des gens qui sont kiki qui ont un
intérêt aussi pour pour décor différent
piccoli il faut aller chercher des
défauts les trouver ces personnes là qui
effectuent un travail à faire au niveau
du casting pour que tout soit et volupté
on voit si je compare un peu à me tendre
l'amour ils ont pris ça se fait
naturellement les gars super beau
casting liberté autant légaux qui les
fait payer sa dîme normal tétine man 2
dans le sens je peux utiliser mon normal
que quatre mois de répression de ce
qu'on retrouve naturellement dans la
population c'est à fait dans tc com
comment est-ce qu'on peut s'inspirer un
peur de 2 comment ils font pour aller
recruter des gens sans nécessairement
pierre de l'aspect du jeu que ce soit -
uniquement axé sur l'apparence que ton
petit moyen de mise et plus sont les
motivations des gens qui d'aller
chercher leur vraie valeur
c'est ce qui s'est dit donc c'est ce
qu'il faut qu'il faut de la diversité
dans les filles font la diversité dans
lego faut pas que ce soit portée par une
seule personne pour aller chercher des
gens c'est ce qu'ils auront un intérêt
qui ne sont plus ouverts par rapport à
tout ce qui est qui
ça permettrait de faire évoluer un peu
plus de la chose puis juste devant toi
qui as he could à une personne un peu le
l'instrumentation jeux présents à
l'enterrement
mais je pense pas mais c'est prêter un
peu des intentions faisant ce jeudi en
lançant ce que j'imagine qu'ils veulent
bien faire mais les traitements
ça a été fait et s'est souvent dressé
justement le titre pour la cause la note
on dirait qu'il y avait quelque chose de
deux spéciales comme ans qui s'est
adressé justement que c'était comme
qu'elles soient trop agressé adressé way
le fait qu'ils aient une participante
qui était différent des autres londres
est qu'ils ont l'adresse est tellement
con à devenir étranger puis mais si je
m'étais moi je je me mets dans la peau
de
une adolescente exemple qui coûte si je
sais pas à quel point fr moi ça me fait
sentir mieux avec le traitement des noms
tout et souvent t on représente
quelqu'un dans un corps plus gros jeu
surprendre positivement cgt a permis
d'avoir ces discussions là justement
aujourd'hui on serait était je pense que
tu m'as tout ce qu'un effet c'est tout
se sait c'est positif mais encore une
fois ça vient renforcer justement le
c'est d'abord ça ça vient renforcer
encore qu'il ya une personne n'a encore
plus gros c'est juste l'axiom de tout le
monde vient pas on va discuter
spectateurs mais lundi c'est je pense
que c'est ça il faut il pour cela que
parle j'ai l'impression de toujours au
niveau du casting mais qu'il faut il
faut être plus inclusif il faut aller
chercher des gens qui ont ces valeurs là
aussi puisqu'ils qui avoir une meilleure
représentation générale de tout petit je
pense qu'il ya un travail à faire cesser
la production peut faire un travail
aussi au niveau de sa gestion des
réseaux sociaux par rapport à tout ce
qui est de continuellement commentaires
grâce aux faibles et tout de
commentaires qui ont eu lieu jeudi pas
vraiment en vue mais je me contente par
les puits
d'éduquer autant la production qu'il est
différent alimentaires aussi qui vont
participer à l'émission l'école et des
gens qui gèrent les réseaux sociaux par
rapport à la gauche aux phobies comme
marc-andré stop parce que le nom de la
campagne c'est si dans le fond c'est
d'après moi c'est la foi sans
commentaire donc c'est cet épi mettons
que c'est par rapport à ce qu on m a
parlé tantôt à temps par rapport à un
gel qui te pousse effets négatifs
d'enfants on tire se pose pas nous
d'être commentant sur l'apparence sur le
poker comme un conte à moi qu'on en
parle et on commente on n'a pas d'enfant
mais on a pas donné un commentaire sur
le physique c'est une question comment
autrement
c'est inquiète et au delà de l'apparence
nous sommes des personnes dans notre
entièreté qui ont énormément de valeur
notre personnalité notre toutes nos
capacités et nos doutes les efforts
qu'on fait tout tout tout près des
avantages elle est recommandée puis
justement la semaine oppose en
commentaire de cette année sa porte soit
l'activité physique mais l'audience a
mené sa portée sur des réseaux sociaux
justement dont commandes que tu peux
commenter différemment thé et une photo
de de ton ami entrejeu passe quand même
graduée mais au lieu de les traiter et
espère bien d'autres acteurs je m'étais
comme félicitations pour tes études
[Rires]
c'est un cas qui est des visites et je
sais que c'est difficile parce que c'est
encore une fois on est beaucoup beaucoup
dans l'image s'appelle le point leurs
effectifs au programme de retravailler
faut arrêter de mettre la beauté comme
la valeur suprême tellement il faut
vraiment revoir ce serait valorisée
autrement dit c'est un peu ce dans le
fond avec la campagne c'est en été
puisque d'intéressant si on l'activité
physique ce qui est souvent tu es quand
on pratique un sport qu'on bouge quand
le sport peut être un petit peu notre
véhicule de trop de travail le cari
beaucoup exposé liminaire puis ça
devient très facile de commenter
d'emblée pitt il en rajoute une couche
puis le tout en un peu plus d'an nom
disparaît de performance parce que là il
peut rester des sports esthétique ou est
ce que c'est ce qu'ils jugent ils
kimi de l'avant qui consomment beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup là dessus
le slogan de campagne cette année 6 me
sur ce que ton corps pour faire parce
qu'il a l'air parce que justement on a
tellement tout le monde tellement de
d'habiles dépit des deux capacités qui
lui permettent de de bouger de
s'exprimer de faire tellement de choses
me sont là dessus des accidents dans le
contexte que le ton dès le moi je pense
ça devrait même pas unique chose qui
devra était comme ça faut arrêter de
médiatiser son appartement
parlons d'autre chose parlons de faire
de la musique ça c'est simple c'est avec
un des six 6 mars qu'une chanteuse les
gens mais tant que tu es que sa musique
n'a aucune idée de quoi là c'est aussi
bon mais ici c'est qu'en mai et 6 2
c'est comme de se penser à fermer ses
yeux agace le cpf pour pas avoir le
filtre du préconçues
un pont pour juste voix rauque est
justement mais pendant l'activité
sportive de voir l'habileté à 20 avant
la grosseur suffisant ça m'a tout quand
on peut être qu'il le faut qu'est ce que
vous avez fait de briser une carla
d'entendre des histoires de détail
casting web c'est vraiment la norme ses
implantations pour ce pauvre dans ledit
par sexualisation ceci est un autre
sujet par rapport à ça aussi je sais pas
si vous avez vu le film qtes énormément
je l'évoquais qui viennent la france va
s'appeler chance les vignes
l'underground mignonne c'est le cover
super cute superbe aux jeunes ados accès
des mecs marge en russie après ça arrive
sont fixes et d'un coup il switch à off
fille à moitié tenu le poste ou
gestuelles le mouvement dans ce qu'ils
font peser comme et confortable veut pas
voir sauter le tout vu le film
non je n'ai pas vu mais je te dis que tu
es super bon mais c'est sale affaire
c'est qu'il ya un gros débat autour de
ce thème la kids est dans le fond le
film est réalisé par une femme efféminé
stick qui elles dénoncent lé but on fait
un film là-dessus je pense être dénoncé
la situation des jeunes filles d'un
milieu de la danse spécifiquement ti qui
pour moi pourrait le dire possiblement
un vrai problème
après ça dans le film il ya des scènes
qui traquent comme spectateur un
confortable parce que tu vois des
petites filles de 12 13 ans tenter de
manière vraiment trop suggestives habile
façon vraiment trop suggestif je me
laisse être en mal et puis il ya des
extraits de ses singles qui en béton
était partagé de facto des réseaux
sociaux puis monde 5
voyons donc qui a ça dans un film sans
aucun sens on puisse timides sont
comptés mais après ça y est même le
débat est ce que même si l'intention est
bonne à ce que ses collègues de le faire
deux femmes faire ces gestes là des
petites filles de 12 ans dans un film
sur les actrices non
actrice n'en qui est bon après si on ne
l'a pas vu facturer des beaux mais c'est
quand même bon débat parce que moi je
pense que l'intention est noble
paraissait mettons aussi je serai dans
le même sens que toi qu'en plus cette
fable en question ne savais même pas la
presse en même temps que tout le monde a
ses valeurs suprêmes message du coup
quand le post une sortie nature x
c'était ok t'es pas au courant de choix
qu'ils ont fait pour ça si c'est
vraiment la touche et dans son négatif
parce qu'elle donne une tête mauvaise
idée de ce que c'est après t'avoir
cliquer dessus
mais un autre tu vois quand même ce film
qui est engagée qui lance le message
à moins que tu le regardes vraiment
injuste aux comme au premier niveau sans
aucune réflexion mais c'était pour venir
au sujet des traits des commentaires
concept qu'est ce qu'on peut faire c'est
moi quand je parle on va dire à d'autres
professeurs je pense côté enseignement
si on a une grosse job ou siloti des
chorégraphies que je vais poster ou que
je vais enseigner
quel genre de musique j'écoute le nombre
de fois que j'entendais musique je vois
des jeunes de 10 ans puis les mots puis
vocabulaire lyrics comme maicon comment
ces sources sortie ou les costumes qu'on
choisit le thème du spectacle c'est tout
ça c'est comme on peut te faire
attention faut vraiment venir en parler
puis faire des choix différents je sais
que ces belles fans de prendre la
chanson top 3 en ce moment c'est à sa
radio mais ça va pas pour ta classe de
12 ans et moins
c'est pour ça que je choisis téthys fait
d'autres choix soit dans cédé 12 ans et
moins sur wap beaucoup moins bien c'est
soit parfois beaucoup c'est sûr qu'il va
beaucoup c'est un autre métier
l'autre des brebis le théron on
n'embarque pas de date parce que c'est
pas le sujet de la journée me disent est
ce que s est ce que ce soit tabou encore
sexualisé ou mauvaise chose en soi
quand la personne là où j'entends un
quad c'est ce que je pense et moi c'est
assez l'aude et comme question le
possible
c'est intéressant qu'à moi je veux dire
ça c'est si j'en parle des fois avec
avec ma gang avec mes danseurs parce que
moi personnellement je suis confortable
on avait parlé justement la donnée de
l'orgie justin timberlake et des vidéos
là encore cette fois ci je pense que je
les fait le travail je me suis mes
limites je me suis dit qu'est ce qui est
acceptable qu'est-ce qu'il va selon mes
valeurs pis avec quoi je confortable
puis moi je suis bien oui j'ai déjà fait
des shoots nu tout ça selon context
sutil ça dépend c'est pourquoi
l'histoire la mission en quoi que ce
soit mais ça c'est moi personnellement
titre no 2 oui exactement
flactif accès devenu et encore une fois
dire aux jeunes c'est m'étais limite tu
es bien en quoi pour toi la question
avant que tu sois sur le spot a
toutefois demandé en passant assez
souhaitons petits costumes décors etc -
et peut-être une pression puis le petit
cochon bientôt pis ces factions gens
parlent beaucoup aux jeunes des de
penser à mettre ses limites ce je pense
que c'est vraiment important aujourd'hui
parce que je m'en allais avec la
question de sexualité tout seul mais
bref moi personnellement je pense que je
me suis posé ces questions là puis le
choix du ch ce que je suis dit c'est pas
parce que moi j'ai fait que pour te
rendre à ma carrière
qu est-ce qu avec qui je danse que poker
farce annoncé ça c'est ce jeu de mains
[ __ ] con pour faire le parallèle avec
la question du poisson sur ce point là
c'est de dire cesser j'imagine
extrêmement difficile pour quelqu'un qui
veut qui aspirent à avoir une carrière
comme la tienne mettons de se dire je
peux le faire en étant en respectant les
valeurs je te manque en prenant les
choix qui sont les miens puis en suivant
pas un parcours comme le tien mettons
way de dire moi
un car je suis plus gros jeu plus
grosses qu'eux mais je suis bien avec ça
j'ai pas besoin de ne pas l'être j'ai
pas besoin d'être plus minces pour avoir
ce succès là mais j'ai l'impression que
c'est extrêmement difficile ça ne doit
pas être extrêmement difficile d'avoir
cette réflexion l'enfant pilote
différent si je pense fondamentale
mettons entre le milieu de la danse
parce que justement versus quelqu'un que
sa plateforme instagram kiki qui sait le
sait le contrôle sur le choix tenté mais
tronquée dans une troupe de danse puis
il ya quelqu'un qui dit voici ton
costume faut que tu le focus est capable
de le mettre
avant le show tipi qui s'est imposé
payer quelqu'un euros qui décide d'un
chausson qui travaillent le chorégraphe
dit supporter ce fait ce versus quand il
en contrôle de tapas terme et à gram tes
limites j'ai l'impression peut-être ce
n'est plus naturellement parce que c'est
vraiment toi qui les fantaisies en haut
pour ce qu'il fait je pense que c'est
important pour la recherche puis le
questionnement personnel avant d'être
mis dans cette situation là pour être
capable de nokia table ça m'est déjà
arrivé le tir non je m'excuse je pas
bien avec cette action-là ce
mouvement-là 7 ce costume bleu puis je
pense que ça vient c'est bien dit avec
du respect pour la personne qui respecte
aussi mais ça passe bien pire au québec
fait soit la place sinon bah tu sais que
tu étais pas de faire partie d'une
équipe ou d'un projet de même - puis sa
ferme la porte puis s'attendent à passer
à quelque chose de mieux pour toi mais
si du site foot soif est forte pour
qu'il connaisse comme du monde pia
qu'elles soient prêtes à mettre pied à
terre puis à peut-être de faire rayer de
cette escale à tout jamais vraiment fait
de conflits de valeurs on en a parlé un
peu de me2 il ya un aspect delà de la
question par rapport aux différents
physique qui est rarement abordé puis
c'est là les commentaires sur la
grandeur des gens on en parle rarement
contre métier mettons cela fait une
énorme tollé les commentaires par
rapport aux pros de julie mettons
occupation de
puis quatre faits sur 8 sur le tapis
rouge je disais moi ça me prendrait au
moins six pieds deux rôles au moins cinq
et 11 puis genre avec ce pilote
il y avait comme rien eu mais moi je
m'appelle on gardait son ensemble que
l'êta comme ces commentaires là on les
entend systématiquement quand est ce
qu'on va là de la ccga caen 5 pi 6 -
comment je me dis qu'en mauricie moi je
demande à tomber si je veux dire nous on
mesure 5 et 11 maintenant on est on est
on est pile la moyenne à gages puis je
bien comporté avec mme appareil qui va
présenter partout mais mettons petite
tête et et au secondaire d'une mesure 5
et 6 août rend compte que tu seras
jamais mesurer plus que 5 et 6 et
peut-être fait de mettre le doigt est un
peu que je mais cgg valide et g je vous
entends non mais je pense que là tu es
comme tu dit et je serai jamais spyder
chirurgie mais la nuance
au niveau de la diversité tout pour
qu'on perde du poids c'est qu'il ya
tellement des moyens pour se rendre au
portugal dans ses caisses et ce qu'ils
en pensent
est-ce que ses associés tels la perte de
poids la glace on s'est entendu possible
alors que la grandeur ben c'est cela
c'est ça le problème
seul problème c'est que ses associés à
une question de volonté
c'est exact et s'il ya bien un facteur
de ta santé de la personne sur les
quelques tenues très très peu de
contrôles ces dons poids et le fait de
penser le fait que tu es avec on parle
de grossophobie et où le fait qu'ici
lequel le projet énormément associé au
fait que c'est une question de volonté
que ça revient à à quelque chose de 13
individuel ça renforce énormément de six
mois ça écrit beaucoup de préjugés et
ccc notamment pour ça qu'il ya autant
qu'avec les commentaires sont autant
d'hommages à autant de répercussions
pitt et c'est pour ça que je dis je vous
entends bhl je trouve ce côté je trouve
que c'est vrai ce que vous dites tout et
pour tout et ça des commentaires sur le
qu'elle soit plus petit que toi plus
grand que tu sais
en effet c'est quelque chose m chevaux
qu'il faut qu'il faudrait adressé mais
c'est juste qu'il faut pour la priorité
non mais t'es c'est tout à fait valide
c'est juste c'est au niveau de du poids
c'est qu'il ya sept
il ya tellement de fausses croyances que
le poète associé à quelque chose qui
contrôle quelque chose qui qui qui
autour de la volonté que c'est ce qu'il
faut pour être compris je vais j'ai posé
une question puis je veux pas qu'on
lance des roches
parce que je pense que ce serait son
père d'une france 2 c'est une question
qui est malgré tout importante à poser
puis que nous on s'est déjà posée qu'on
a déjà parlé dans un podcast notamment
avec lee bernard de faire machine de
dire ce que tu viens d'ouvrir c'est à
dire c'est à dire le poids
c'est quelque chose que tu peux pas
contrôler il ya des études qui
démontrent que maintenant il ya beaucoup
de maladies qui sont liés un surpoids
mais ton qui est un réel problème qu'on
qu'on ne peut pas vraiment ému at il dit
ou est ce que en fait ce sera pas une
question sérieuse doit tout va lancer la
discussion
ou est-ce qu'on trace cette ligne si je
combine le point de dire
ne parlons pas du pot des gens se sait
que c'est sain j'ai rien à dire le tc
comment papa se dit pas un commentaire
sur le poids de quelqu'un qui datent
site le tout s'est réglé ce qui ce qui
est une notion facile à comprendre mais
ton mais ses médecins dit à quelqu'un
mais ton mais citons pas de créer des
problèmes qui sont python pur ailier a
par exemple dont mode de vie kiki
sédentaires qui est qui est ce que tu
manges plus mal pleure quand j'ai
l'impression de marcher sur des oeufs
parce que je suis de fonction dans ce
débat là je pense que c'est important
fait quoi est ce contrat se tue moi
maintenant quand je vois quelqu'un qui
est un embonpoint qui a de la misère à
se lever d'une chaise puis qui juste à
615 ne pas être capable de respirer
clairement dit clairement polaire
physiquement en santé qu'est-ce qu'on
combatte avoue-t-il dans cette question
là le hetet je baille trop loin là
dedans parce qu'il ya comme toute la
science po si c'est tellement complexe
le pour le poste est complexe c'est
quand je peux essayer de répondre
d'insulté oui c'est vraiment important
quand même d'amener sur ouï oui tout à
fait et disent justement ça comptait en
comprenant mieux ça permet aussi de
distinguer des brise est prise en
fausses croyances là on va rentrer
console après avoir dit toute la bande
je pense que vous l'avez un peu abordée
mais j'avais écouté avec berne en jeu
je reprends un peu ce qu'ils sont ce
qu'ils ont déjà bien plein dans ma
réponse mais tu es le le poids c'est un
facteur 30 de la santé c'est loin d'être
le seul puis comme je disais c'est loin
d'être lui sur lesquels une personne a
le plein contrôle donc autour du pot ya
énormément de facteurs qui viennent
qu'ils viennent influencer nos
comportements qui est france qui peuvent
influencer le poids donc il ya des étés
s'il ya des lieux des yeux rien mais
c'est ça c'est ça la nuance c'est que
c'est un stand est en cause a une cause
des coûts de l'étude
c'est exactement ça c'est super
important comprendre qu' à tcc davantage
nos habitudes de vie qui vont avoir un
impact beaucoup plus direct sur la santé
et quand on vient uniquement misé sur le
bois
mais quand c'est bloqué c'est comme
ailleurs il faut absolument que tu me
dis si ton poulain mais les gens vont et
c'est le poids c'est un comportement ont
recours à des affaires malsaine pour
atteindre cet objectif
exactement qui s'applique alors que la
mettons la perte de poids minime et de
remettre une résultante d'un changement
de laisser sa prime
moi je vais présenter comme quand c'est
comme ça que je les présentais je suis
comme c'est un effet secondaire a peur
ça peut leur arriver
mais quand une approche uniquement axé
sur ge power
ben là ça fait en sorte qu'ils aient
constaté je peux avoir un métier avait
mangé une manière plus plus d'équilibré
des 2 commence à cuisiner de tout
arrêter de fumer et plein d'éléments au
niveau des habitudes que tu pars pour
changer mais s'il n'ya pas de changement
sur la balance c'est comme un échec qui
a monté ça peut fonctionner mais au
contraire sa nouvelle pelouse en santé
si elle mange lupia bouge plus
exactement donc quitté ccc ce qu'ils
font un peu comprendre pour comprendre
aussi que c'est pas une question comme
je dis tant d'autres une question de
volonté que c'est pas dès qu'il ya un
lien mais c'est pas le seul c'est pas
sur lui sur lequel on en plein contrôle
qui fait devenir miser là dessus c'est
extrêmement stigmatisant qui seul axe
thématisation on s'en rend de plus en
plus compte à quel point c'est un énorme
risque pour la santé aussi
indépendamment de temps de ton poids si
tu vis de la stigmatisation
par rapport à ton poids ça peut avoir
des répercussions autant sur ta santé
mentale le stress que ça gêne horaires
des liens directement sur ta sur ta
santé de france notamment aux maladies
cardiovasculaires par exemple qui est je
crois hélas non plus par ce biais c'est
quand même nouveau nul mais il n'oublie
style le reconnaissent de plus ils
reconnaissent la stigmatisation pour
avoir énormément compté qu'en ce qui est
juste cinq ans mais qui justement sauter
je manquais c'était chose comme les
personnes qui sont stigmatisés par
rapport à leur poids en soit et le taux
de mortalité est près de 60 fois plus
élevé celles qui ont 60% plus de chance
vous toute mentalité le mastic est en
train de mal tourner mais est factice
c'est aussi ça peut il ya beaucoup de
recherche encore qui reste à faire il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup d'études ou six
conteneurs en ce moment par rapport à
tout ce qui
tout ce qui tourne toi qui qui peut
décemment contrôle et pour plein de
variables différentes comme le white
cycling comme le thon historique de
régime comme l'interprète chose qui qui
manque le progrès pour eux pour aller
plus loin parce qu'on est déjà beaucoup
plus loin qu'en réalité je pense que le
domaine réalise il progresse on sait en
ce sens
bref tout pour disons le en résumé
lequel la caisse estime olympique a misé
uniquement serait pas au beaucoup
beaucoup de conséquences
donc c'est ma face à très haut risque
j'attendais que c'est même le stigma il
existe même au sein de professionnels de
la santé
si je te mettre simple je reçois une
personne un bon point mais peut-être que
les billets soient médecins et le ou les
préjugés wazemmes ce patient l'oeil et
peut-être justement moins de volonté il
veut pas céder aussi où ce billet tant
qu'à moi ça c'est très con trats poteau
il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
justement
on s'appelle nous ça peut nuire à la
santé parce que tu as peur d'aller sais
pas si tu sais que tu vas te faire dire
que j'ai mal au genou belle part du
power pickett et côté c'est comme des
peut considérer dans comme comme une
autre personne l'estrie où est-ce qu'ils
ont investi crée davantage pied
mettez-vous de personnes qui rapporte
que justement ils se sentent moins bien
traités qui ont pas dit soins qui sont
les serments il table par rapport à
d'autres si si c'est quelque chose qui
traient problème trop bas ou de vue
beaucoup d'heures de nutrition dans le
parcours musical dont nous avons
beaucoup mais ça c'est un enjeu
important qui était on voit la question
comment est encore beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de travail à faire
mais avec justement les niveaux garonne
qui vient de sortir le on s'est mis de
l'avant avec la climatisation un impact
non négligeable d'une caisse a glissé
site
comment parce qu'il est ce que du moment
quelqu'un dit je veux perdu tous ses
jeux phares une perte de pau est ce que
quelqu'un dise eux il est déjà quelque
chose de problématique dans le fait de
désirer heures de pomas section est ce
que est ce que juste le fait de vouloir
ce ca
c'est justement à cause que microsoft si
à cause qui on est on est bombardé une
certaine idée de centaines des halles
puis c'est le décor soit qui qu'il faut
perdu pour maintenant moi je dis ça
défoule moi je suis là je dois perdre du
poids alors qu'elle est en forme et en
santé arrange bien
gpj tu es ma bouche beaucoup société
malade et c'est justement il faut il
faut regarder c'est tellement quelque
chose qu'on se le dire constat c'est sûr
tu mets ton quand j'ai dit sur mes
motivations sont essayé d'avoir un six
pack qui ressort plus que maintenant
maintenant c est ce que ça me met on
excuse moi mais heureux la question
c'est idriss pour toi la question
fondamentalement est ce que est ce que
c'est juste un petit buzz moi j'ai
besoin c'est ce qu est ce que le
processus se rendrait plus heureux sur
le sommet tant parce que maintenant dire
je me perds du pôle est ce ça voudrait
dire le temps qui est là je veux
m'entraîner plus fort puis faire
attention plus à ce que je mange qui 2a
frère qui dans le processus
au final ferait que j'avais sûrement des
meilleures nuits de sommeil
j'aurais sûrement t1 plus d'énergie
j'aurais sûrement tout ceux d'un
processus samassa sera positif dans ma
vie en est on mais ce béton mettons que
je réprouve après
[Musique]
c'est ça c'est maintenant les mâles une
manière saine à guez de perdre du poids
sous quel signe madame marcelle donc
c'est pas l'importance police peau la
paire de pousser le slam au nord du
brésil
seulement si l'agitation et j'avais
souffert plus d'activité physique trouve
davantage me dis encore une fois comme
jeudi le poids c'est pas un comportement
c'est pas quelque chose qui qui
facilement changeable d'effets
secondaires a possiblement m'étais perdu
pour accéder par ckoi qui s'est rendu
c'est des questions plus clinique le
haut niveau de la personne qu'on reçoit
c'est sûr que quand un esthète demande
l'heure on exploit hors tickets ce qui
est acquis et pourquoi ces caisses qui
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qui en arrière
de ce qu'est ce qui reflète si clint
choses à les questionner je pense que ça
d'emblée s'arrêteront s'agissant réflète
quelque chose au niveau 2 comme tu dis
est il là on a l'impression que c'est ce
qu'il faut faire pour être bien mais on
apprécie beaucoup
[Musique]
mixeur encore une fois comme je disais
ah ah ah ah j'aime sortir plus heureuse
va être plus jamais langon corp
disposait qui arrive c'est une perte de
postes ça va pas nécessairement de faire
sentir comme ça mène pas vers
l'acceptation et ou de santé ont
nécessairement plus heureux c'est le
plein de choses le quai sur ses six
filles ont beau vouloir miser davantage
sur ce terreau jazz qui t on sait que
plus tu es plus que quelqu'un est
préoccupé plus tu vas aller vers des
moyens qui sont dangereux pour la santé
qui ne fonctionne pas à long terme soit
enfin conséquence aussi belle de toutes
les 10 à tous qu'on a fait est bon et
c'est ce bernois de la femme installée
14 et tous à 90 pour ça et ça c'est fou
ce que j'imagine qu'on avance dans ta
carrière
ça devait pas être monnaie courante de
parler de dire je bâtis d'un côté une
ballerine tout ça c'est vraiment toi
notre département je me lancerai pas
dans parce que c'est pas mon ami mais je
sais que le sait sont paisibles c'est
vraiment quelque chose puis thil a lâché
être importante note ici mais c'est plus
et commente ça physiquement tu as de la
de quoi pas nécessairement un shift et
pour ton pas exactement métier comme
exemple catherine de mentionner c'est
perdre un peu de prototypage et j'ai
pensé pendant ce temps-là qobuz com - de
ces chirurgies un appel puis qu'il faut
je pense moi j'aimerais perdre un peu de
poids pas prêt je me suis mais je te
sentes et ça vaut bien
je crois même physique je prends des
marches puis je danse de temps en temps
il faut que je corrige tout si c'est
paul amar deux c'est plus de suite j'ai
vu que c'est mon conditionnement danser
c'est que j'ai de suite pensé aux petits
costumes puis mon ventre à l'air fait
que je pense que c'est juste moi je vois
qu'il faut que je travaille ça c'est de
la loire que sa vie de ce
conditionnement là mais oui c'est pas
présent j'ai un ami le gecko mythiques
comme un peu connus comme pour ça en
arrivant à los angeles un gardien aussi
puis il ya son corps je dis tu es tout
mince pas précis d'un coup ils
commençaient à lodja chaque jour puis de
mus par bob bleu c'était le gars qui
bouquet tout les artistes surtout des
artistes féminines qui sans chandail que
c'est quand même la pression c'est puis
en parler ouvertement que l'anxiété la
dépression petite soupe c'est beaucoup
de pression parce que c'est comme mon
cher petit moineau jim tout simple il
recevait des appels puis 10 et non
directement isolé même pas la chance de
hockey oui il s'est dit ensuite on
m'appelle pour parce que on cite mon
corps raide la dette sans ce moment mais
c'est paul coffey que j'ai à dire dont
je peux poste occupé ces mêmes pages de
voir qu'à qui fait que sedin ont
l'argent à des opportunités à tout ça
pis s'ils avaient dit oui j'imagine que
le monde
c'est le monde me semble que c'est le
fun tarkan est aussi dense que tu vois
le type je pense que c'est le principe
de la diversité mais même pitié mais ton
t on a parlé d'un certain chaud que
j'avais fait les paul était passé
l'autre d'avancé toute chose une chose
que je trouvais le fun c'est que il y
avait quand même des castings différent
il y avait un danseur qui était gros le
menton puis il y avait aussi le monde de
toutes sortes d'or je me dis mais je me
tenais ma tante un téléphone et il y
avait une femme le petit plus de plus
proche de mon nom je les tire là
d'autres posent souvent les commentaires
qui sortait justement sur ces
différences le sur justement dans le
danseur gros ou sur qui je pense les
gens sont contents crime d une diversité
choses plus très de reconnaître ktm
parce qu'on faisait en tout il est filmé
partie de ses specs de diversité cowboys
qui représentait présent c'est sympa
sans la cei pour ça c'est que ce gars-là
c'est dans sherlock les rencontres et
qui est trop in sainte croix et qu'il
lui doit être plus proche de tout le
monde n'en fourie que 5% c'est à peu
près le plus intéressant ça nous permet
d'aller un peu plus peut-être dans la
thématique d'activité or tout ce qui
t'est c'est ce qu'on observe c'est quand
et l'insatisfaction de fond est relié à
comme budgétaire à plein d'éléments
anxiété dépression estime de soi social
au décrochage scolaire mais notamment
c'est un énorme obstacle à l'adoption de
saines habitudes de vie qui incarne
quand on regarde un peu plus au niveau
de l'activité physique
mais les satisfactions ça peut autant
mener à une pratique excessive non
sécuritaire qu' un abordage
c'est notamment quelque chose qu'on
observe beaucoup chez les filles
présentement ses étés à la
préadolescence il ya vraiment un début
de décrochage d'activité physique qui se
passe et et ça continue dans le fond à
travers le secondaire d'augmenter c'est
à peu près une fille sur 10 le qui m'ont
pas répondre aux recommandations
canadiens nos mesures d'activité
physique à la fin du secondaire
c'est en dessous dans le fond qui font
penser quand même 45 minutes par jour
mais nous avons envoyé ou si j'avais lu
me semble que c'était une fille sur deux
ne délaissant sa bande qui avait proposé
ce sont les facteurs cesser ses
pressions notamment constaté qu'un
énorme été beaucoup de chance de
remporter des grands chantiers notamment
type d'accident est en fait pour qu'ils
veulent pas faire de sport
faire rire d'eux justement si tu es
aussi quelque chose au niveau de tomber
dans les stéréotypes excellente mais dès
que le sport est souvent associée encore
plus masculin est dans la perception
qu'ils ont de quoi une fille en guinée
doit ressembler mastic encore plus que
l'iran devait en fonction des normes
qu'on a en ce moment
kiki pub tv qui ont peur des par exemple
prendre au muscle lyon parle de se faire
juger des faits nous épaule
[Musique]
mes gardes mais ces sautes effet que ça
l'a pas la part aussi le regard des
autres le fait coiffer les maquis
pendant l'activité physique dont c'est
plein de choses à venir mais qui
marchent pas pour elle c'est un enjeu
majeur est aussi tête la fameuse enquête
vous parlais tantôt avec le plus d'un
jeune sur deux on voit que des jeunes
qui qui essaye de contrôler leur poids
d'une différentes façons 65% de son
recours peuvent avoir recours à au moins
une méthode dangereuse pour y arriver
puis dans cette enquête là on voit que
74% des jeunes qui essaient de contrôler
leur poids ont déjà fait au moins une
fois une pratique excessive affectif
quand tu parle de méthodes dangereuses
pratique excessive on parle de quoi
mettons des diètes extrême des bourses
je peux te donner trop de hauts niveaux
de contrôle de l'alimentation qui voit
des jus pendant 12 jours le maton web et
il s'écrit pas plus globale que ça me
tombe par rapport à ce qu'ils ont mesuré
le may 8 6 à tourner lentement autour de
te qui tente et on voit là que j'ai
vraiment sept sapeurs autant contribuer
décrochage que ça peut aussi un stand
relation plus malsaines peut-être avec
avec l'activité physique donc de rester
on veut oublier ce qu'elle menait avec
les a toutes ces informations mais quand
il veut aller loin mais pour la campagne
qui tous que tout ce qu'on qu'on met en
place et on voit que les commentaires ça
peut vraiment avoir une incidence sur
cette insatisfaction morel qui peut
causer toute cette panoplie de deux
problématiques factice et c'est super
important de miser d'où la campagne de
miser sur ce que notre corps nous permet
de faire ou aller au delà de l'apparence
de l'activité physique est tellement
davantage sur plein de sons de faire
exactement qui est notamment l'activité
physique va permettre test associé à ça
permet d'avoir une image corporelle plus
positive arabe là à la bande s'est
associé à une masse corporelle plus
positif dans le sens où est ce qu'il ya
comme un phénomène
tu peux trouver un terme en français
pour cela je faisais le mba limiter la
capacité des plus connectés de
reconnaître ses capacités qui doit
vraiment être vraiment connecter
davantage à notre core ppi de ce que
notre corps nous permet de faire dans le
fond qui
qui permet justement de sentir plus à ty
plus satisfait de son corps de ses
capacités seul environnement sportif
peut vraiment venir à voiron
l'environnement fait sportif peut
contribuer à un facteur de risque à ce
que tous les différentes choses qui
donnent et rennes qui peuvent et ont
affecté dont les commentaires qui se
retrouve pas je trouve ça vraiment
intéressant de mentionner que l'activité
physique et permet de sentir ce comme un
peu on extrait s'intitule ses com -
tafer - ty 5e malaise dans ton corps
puis le moins du temps les en a encore
moins de tous en enfer à cause de toutes
les commentaires faits que ces messieurs
l'elysée cette roue le cabcl 81 [ __ ] et
peut-être toute confiance en ses
capacités non c'est une estime de soi
plus élevé plus que tu vas être
satisfait par rapport à ton corps
dimanche 12 ou encore que tu aimes ainsi
un corps dans tous les autres ont besoin
c'est donc tout un lien qui justement tu
dois avoir plus envie de pratiquer des
activités visées pour pour le plaisir
pour l'épanouissement petit tout ça
c'est aux 500 qui sert clerc qui commet
un éphèbe direction et tous ces bons
[Rires]
donc mais c'est sa maman ne pas être
apte à la parité des facteurs de
l'environnement sportif henri excuse à
pied avec le règlement
basket certains certaines activités
sportives ont développé ton corps d'une
certaine façon ça c'est sûr et certain
fait puis il ya aussi encore les mêmes
les mêmes préjugés justement comparé les
profils sexuelle de dire une fin il faut
que ce soit filiforme puis mettons pour
prendre l'exemple la natation c'est
meilleur exemple c'est les épaules qui
sont ultra large celle là tu puis ne
font plus en guinée car rhénatic en plus
associé au masculin
j'imagine que ça ça dissuade défi de
continuer d'affecter béton pour un gosse
dans un support béton comme le cyclisme
est ce que le sais ce que tu veux c'est
d'être le plus mini possible sur ton
vélo mais ils y apprennent qu'ils vont
pas le faire parce que le pape parce que
c'est parce que tu veux excuse moi mais
c'est ce que ça fait ben sur le vélo
tellement longtemps s'est quand même tu
deviens ultra minces se développe au
score alors que ce qui va être
exactement s'il trouve à la risée
d'avoir des pectoraux des 10 70 qui en
fait ce qu'on voit c'est chez les
athlètes comme un phénomène de double
image corporelle c'est là quand j'ai lu
ça je suis trouvé en bonne chose parce
que j'ai toujours ressenti mais tu es je
lisais ce qui justement t on voit qui
est églises étaient de façon générale il
rapporte une meilleure satisfaction
corporels que les noms athlètes
notamment pour plusieurs raisons parquet
t il sont plus en contact avec leurs
capacités sont plus en mesure de de
d'être en contact avec avec toute cette
fonctionnalité le
notamment qui dans le vent on voit
qu'ils aient dépendamment de son sport
orthez tout le monde est un peu tout et
les artisans nippon n'avait pas sur
notre planète où tout affecté aussi par
l'image des eaux
quand on veut piquer dans dance dans ce
monde là bas on a le milieu sportif qui
est lui aussi des idées opinions tout
aussi irréaliste dessous de la société
de foi parfois financés par le jeune
homme en qui sont tes appels selon une
logique dans ce que j'ai vu de gender
normes gips brut west kent on espère
justement comment notation ou est ce qu
est la norme peut chanter ou sur la
norme sociale y avait plus les tuyaux
comme un décalage entre la demande et de
plus que quelqu'un peut vie de
l'insatisfaction corporelle ou la ps3
soit réellement intéressante si j'ai un
monde aux antilles ont notamment donné
quand même temps qu'un autre est au pied
souvent ressentie justement
par rapport aux aztèques lâche le cas il
n'y a pas de pandémie mondiale le chemin
du cros fiche de ses conversations avec
des filles dans dignité parce que je te
montrer des filles qui font du crossfit
viennent s'y ajouter
10h10 pidal le jeans et le 3 1 tient pc
ultra pas encourager la société s'est
souvent fait associe à des bonnes
performances qui justement il ya une
espèce de pas de fierté métier de comme
des dépanneuses d'épanouissement à
l'intérieur du gym mais de complexes à
l'extérieur durant
c'est un drôle de fan ça fait acté c'est
doc est justement qu'on voit qu'on quant
aux mises davantage
d'où l'importance de créer des
environnements sportifs qui vont miser
au delà de l'apparence puis qui vont
valoriser les athlètes ils sportif ne
porteront leurs ongles et comme ce que
je vous dis plus remarquée au niveau des
acquêts temps plein mais pour tout le
monde d'avoir des milieux qui sont moins
focalisé sur l'apparence qu'ils sont
bien plus faux que ses soeurs lettre au
lieu de pareilles aussi vont davantage
miser sur les habiliter les efforts
l'état demain les doutes que ton corps
est capable de faire qu'est-ce qui
permet d'accomplir qu'est ce qui te
permettent d'exprimer c'est super
important de miser la cupiste sa peugeot
c'est ça ça peut être un facteur
protecteur je te rends compte l'objectif
ication du milieu de la performance et
notamment c'est un petit peu nos
messages à travers ce qu'on met de
l'avant pour ayons pu dessus s'il vous
plaît théo notre corps nous permet de
faire tellement de chance et c'est beau
c'est vrai rosé c'est quand je pense à
tout ce qui
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire dans une
journée c'est vraiment beau que c'est là
dessus qu'on veut davantage miser puis
pour juste sur de quoi qu'il leur parce
que
boudou être le fun au site oui c'est
vrai des jeunes sur deux qui dit qu'ils
finissent par avoir tout ça mais c'est
comme on peux-tu sont pas rendus à des
niveaux aussi sera l'hôte en espérant
qu'ils rendu adultes plus mature tu peux
faire des meilleures décisions mais si
dès le début de tout jeune j'ai toujours
agi parce que on dit sur des coteaux la
physique parce que si on en parle
beaucoup en alimentation tickets
quant aux plus de plaisir les chances
que ce soit intenable et chance
exactement la même chose à manger puis
alors dif en affaires le sport qui s'y
met ton - qui agit justement découvert
les creux du cross j'ai vraiment arriver
lochte a laissé ce pigeon m6 puis le
appréciée y aller si jamais devenu t
trouverez les et c'est un plaisir d'y
aller puis s'installe found ce puits
jamais jamais jamais ton grand mon
métier ma motivation ayala ces projets
vous m entraîne aujourd'hui parce que je
je sois père du projet avantage de corse
et comme j'aime cela fait bien c'est une
orque cependant match dans mon corps
puis je me déporte puis je vois du monde
qui s'en sort de mon milieu
c'est ça ça me prendrait du beau monde
pour toutes ces raisons là j'avais du
plaisir et aller pitié puis par la bande
évidemment mais dans mon cas c'est
transformé sauf que justement jamais
faux cul c'est là dessus que tu sais
même pas s'il défend déjà remarqué dans
ce sens que quatre russes a trouvé ce
cécile hockey s'il est à nous pas nous
ici
si c'est pas mal ça c'est pas une
pression sociale c'est juste des
activités sportives que tu as envie de
pâques procure du plaisir phi phi coup
c'est une cuisine les bleus quelques est
qu'ils sont bons c'est pire c'est comme
tu dit et si tu avais eu une approche
plus d'heures qu'il faut que ça soit
pour changer mon apparence et tout son
lot mais ça c'est pas durable
c'est pas durable d'autres
problématiques ousty fait le plaisir
c'est vraiment la base de toute chose
qui je trouve ça vraiment triste - de
voir à quel point tu es quand on regarde
le milieu de la haute performance cible
peur ça la tendance a découlé des mois
un peu partout ces deux ans et qu'il
avait eu des témoignages pour travailler
des personnes qui disent que c'est même
moi j'avais 8 9 ans puis mon coach de
nancy c'est ton prof de danse de 10 à
baillet lasserai jamais fatigué tu te
fais dire ça dangereux
c'est sûr que c'est si ça peut
contribuer au fait que sa tante pupilles
à baraki mais moi je serai pas car tu as
fait qu'on sait c'est si les lettres ou
rien wes cates et saisissez sur
seulement 10 l'élite
oui ou sinon ça vaut pas la peine
l'impact que la performance
le prof c'est la performance est partout
mais qu'en pense aux sports je trouve ça
je trouve qu'il faut pour faut
absolument qu que ce soir un x sur
lesquels ont mis en doute il est un peu
différent les gens quand et j'ai pas
fait pour perdre du poids ou changer ma
chef c'était juste un effet secondaire
la nuit je fais cela parce que ça me
fait faire de ces sommes
ça me fait du bien j'ai du plaisir à le
faire une prépa je me dépasse
les gens me l'ont fait remarquer ça le
réputé ce jeu demain qu'on parlait d'un
taux des commentaires positifs des
compliments ou le fait de miser sur
l'apparence genre de commentaires qui
qui aurait pu comme renforcer un peu
quelque chose où il faut faire
en fait c'est que mentalement pour lui
dire ce qu'on veut dégager davantage ces
latitudes qui aurait pu commenter au
lieu la chute et j'ai dit ça c'est sûr
qu'ils aiment et on le sait déjà fait
demander que c'est pertinent personnes
les nuances et et c'est pas non plus que
l'apparence de vienne j'ai su le montat
boucle depuis jamais le droit de dire à
ton ami qui a et b non plus c'était ce
que je voulais dire pas ma question
un peu plus tôt le dre comment qu'on a
parce que c'est ce que veut ce que cette
vie tabou point qui est le seul sujet
que le nom c'est dans ce genre de glee
fox est aux faucons farineau
commentaires puis je pense qu'ils
étaient dans le fond tat belle pub parce
qu'ils te perds 10 pas où te changer ou
te telle ou telle chose au niveau d'un
corps elle met un tvt rayonnante
aujourd'hui par confiante tête et
hébétée on peut être beau et belle pour
prouver une chose qui est quelle
apparence il s'est davantage note reçue
tout organisé par le sport phare de ce
pari même si moi je le vois je l'entend
partout quitter cette survalorisation
par rapport à l'apparence dès qu'on est
tout petit la tendance demain plus vers
les filles de dire estimé baek les
garçons c'est qu'on était forte mais
c'est aussi les enfants y étaient pas eu
l'oeil prennent tout seul ça peut
ramener du domaine survalorisation des
vieux bus mais tous pour dire que que ce
soit le plaisir c'est pas les bras
plusieurs téléphones jamais qu'un quart
est mentionné ton tour le sait le
l'excellence découle tout le reste
4-4 rendu en même temps à autre la
pyramide se sera rendu le temps de deux
idéogrammes pour gagner des millièmes de
seconde mais ton sur ton vélo le tuer ou
de modifier maintenance l'équivalent de
modifier la voiture un petit écrou vers
la droite le titre qui était un athlète
professionnel d'excellence qui fait ça
de sa vie puis qu'il fait dans l'optique
de maximiser à 100% sa performance ça
c'est quelque chose qui fait entourer de
100 tours et d'insertion professionnelle
puisque ce sont son corps s'y sont
toutefois persuadés de finale des
pyjamas pour ce qui est de la relance
puis quelle impression
si je dois pour se rendre le hobson
avoir ces décisions là à prendre tes pas
t'es pas des millièmes de seconde près
le cfi points 0 1% et 0 000 000 000 1
pour cent le terrain comme fait de base
et tout un système
mais dont le theux janet johnson mais
fut ma plus d'actualité mais mettons
tous les meilleurs cyclistes au monde
que christopher froome qui est en haut
puis l'a presque toutes les délégations
de cyclisme canada de pierre ferland qui
sont encore du sport de haut niveau et
représente un autre couche en dessous
d'eux comme tout les clubs de cyclisme
du vélo c'est quand même un peu dessus
comme quand sera rendu à côté de lui en
haut lieu peut-être qu'on peut calculer
ces affaires là quand ça aura un impact
il sera entouré de gens qu'ils font tic
comme du monde et on sait que tout à
fait tilt pour moi ils entendent en
nuance importante la pratique d'activité
physique global est le haut a dit parce
que même si cela te dis aux tirs 3
mettront le cadre de ce que je faisais
on s'entend ce qu'on fait c'est de
l'ailette là au délitement et multi mais
même au niveau que moi j'étais système
s'était même pas triste est même pas un
enjeu mon poids le tir est techniquement
en plus ça aurait amené aucune
différence dans mon classement
canadien au mondial et y fait même boya
déjà au une fois au une fois sa passe
est trop qui est deux fois et encore là
je pense que la différence plus tôt mais
le otelli le déplore encore le tri
sélectif oui pour certaines disciplines
à un certain niveau
le poids pour avoir peut être un facteur
à considérer mais comme je disais tantôt
ça reste un facteur ça reste un facteur
parmi tous les éléments de la
performance qui encore une fois c'est
pas lui sur lequel on venise et parce
que ce ça peut avoir une conséquence qui
malheureusement dans ce port ce pour
vraiment ce qui ce premier soutien l'on
veuille sais vraiment pas ce qui se
passe vite et je faisais c'est une
importance de vraiment à diminuer
l'importance accordée au poids même
dansé dansé dans ces milieux dans ce
contexte l'heure c'est on le sait que
les athlètes de les athlètes de haut
niveau sont plus à risque de troubles
alimentaires consensuellement la
population générale
c'est utilisé en jeu mais moi ça me fait
des ravages sur tes j'ai fait un jeu
partout jours de wimbledon parce que je
les mandats mais j'ai fait une
collaboration avec eux dernièrement qui
samedi il fallait que j'écrive un
article là dessus et puis pour vrai jeu
l'écran fin de semaine puis si ça fait
huit ans maintenant les premiers
retraite puis je broyais du stade
jusqu'à savenay tellement cherché mais
tg on était dans ces milieux là le corps
il ya thème une importance démesurée est
apportée par rapport à la performante
que moi j'ai toujours senti que mon
corps aurait été objective objectifs et
aux alliances de la performance piqué
tessa a effectué ma relation avec mon
corps avec la nourriture avec l'activité
physique avec la sexualité g10 a eu des
répercussions vraiment importantes puis
tu es les athlètes c'est comme une si
c'est bon ou les inquiète c'est commencé
vers 6 est l'ultime représentation de la
performance
grecque le métier on n'est pas des
grandes
on n'est pas des machines on est des
vrais puis en haut comme il faut c'est
sabine chercher des petits faut il faut
il faut voir ce différemment qu'il faut
changer la culture du sport à ce niveau
là qui moi c'est un peu ses créations
cette façade est venue de plus en plus
simplement ma mission
oui mitigées à travers la campagne on
est déçu par partenaires qui nous qui
nous soutiennent depuis tout le monde
sait tout le monde et comme hui ce temps
restant très bien mon idée et nono tout
du tout du tout petits aux plus vieux on
voit des problématiques qui tout le
monde embarque le petit tout le monde
c'est pas juste équilibre qui porte ce
besoin là c'est vraiment senti au niveau
de plein d'organismes et plein de
partenaires différents puis je pense que
ati qui débuteront pour aller changer de
culture sportive
aussi si bing
mais que moi j'ai l'espoir qu'on va être
capable de faire évoluer les choses qui
de faire changer cette ce discours là
que l'importance que qui misé là dessus
parce que ça hypothèque une ville quand
c'était vraiment intéressant ce que tu
dis par rapport aux athlètes parce que
si on lit mais vraiment survie des
stades comme les grisailles pics et si
si comme s'ils disent ils modèlent le
sait maintenant à 2008 ou est-ce que
wasquehal à tout
chaque fois qu il demandé sur un bloc
qui parlait de son corps comme une
voiture
ouais c'est ça pis à ces niveaux-là
performante une pression qui est
justement d'aider jusqu'à l'impression
que c'est du si bon exemple à suivre que
c'est tellement infime partie de la
population qui ont une relation
probablement malsaine avec
l'entraînement puis avec toutes sortes
de pour être à ce niveau de performance
vous soit complètement
c'est complètement dédié à une seule et
petite enfance qui la magie gravats des
populations c'est c'est possible c'est
pas vraiment ça avoir une vie équilibrée
c'est peu de vie équilibré
donc si on peut trouver ça beau
quelqu'un qui était de sa vie à quelque
chose le culte à l'aller de performances
au lit avec sais pas qui est ce on veut
pas appliquer ce com comme règle de vie
le tri à s'inquiéter puis j'ai pas
vraiment mtg peut-être beaucoup encore
de lecture là dessus ce que josy
m'intéresse par quoi je serais curieux
d'aller regarder mon temps libre
mais j'ai plein de questionnements -
récemment par rapport à justement tu es
l'importance qu'on accorde à la
performance puis jusqu au nom de la
performance qui s'est pas supposé être
la performance au delà de la chanter non
c'est pas si c'est si wes hic on s'est
perdu là dedans
qu'est ce qui se passe qui est de type
différent le documentaire de will have
gone
non je n'ai pas écouté finalement c'est
un somme ce sens au fait c'est pas mal
et séduit au fond ce n'est pas ce que je
racontais grosse dépression après les
olympiques de littéralement le revers de
la médaille le pis je trouve t on et de
l'autre ces personnes le petit garçon je
prendrai le côté moins bon en arrière on
le voit jamais quelqu'un tentant mais ça
va ça vient chercher parce que justement
on voit quel point à quel point la
performance et comme la performance à
tout prix y est après cet aveu pas le
sport c'est ses bottines junkie mais
quand j'en parle de l'histoire qui il
demande désormais au tour gré tu sais ce
que tu leur frère qui m'a sans que je le
respecte comme ça sans hésiter je
regrette pâte et le sport ça m'a apporté
tellement bien faire tellement de choses
et ça m'a pris plein enfants et des
choses qui qui l'utilisent pour avis
telle était la collaboration le fait de
jeter d'apprendre comment gérer la
victoire j'ai eu de l'échec tuyaux
prompte à peine chose que qui s'amarrent
unis c'est sûr que je si je pouvais
changer quelques jours ce serait de
changer
l'important ce qui justement lisseur
l'apparence pile poil j'adore cac était
en position d'autorité de l'impôt et
quand 12 13 14 5 centimes consistait à
faire et c'est ce que je discutais avec
kim t on mais c'est ce que je trouve
difficile c'est que moi j'ai vécu tu es
le plus aux demandes de 2
ma carrière si on veut tgv 16 septembre
je t'ai pas en mesure de savoir ce qu'on
est en train de me dire été moustène
normal le communiste comme comme si
j'étais aucunement en mesure d'avoir un
jugement critique plus visités plus
apprécié du thé quand j'ai changé de
coach tout seul il ya des arrêts qui se
passe et que je suis mais je n'ai pas
encore non plus à cet argent mesures dès
maintenant de médiator comme c'est
possible
[Musique]
on en parlait comparativement mois kim
bleus vont me demanda si tu es un
désavantage commencé à trop traîner ces
ménages à vingt dix ans à los angeles
des vieilles team mais c'est avec des
discussions comme ça tu sais pas
travailler années que je quitte un jour
nouveau
ça m'a vraiment aidé et il a confiance
savoir chikhi quoi c'est non merci
at-elle commentaires si je ne prends pas
je le retiens beauté mais oui tout petit
je pense que je pense peut-être temps à
parler justement d'être sur des idées
des jeunes soir dans son sport si on a
tout dit trop d'horreurs le par rapport
à ce type i puis justement quand t'es
jeune t'es peut-être moins capable de
reconnaître quand est ce qui est de la
relation avec ton coach des relations
est passé n'est pas normal enfin que
c'est tout petit dernier de changer de
côté d'eyepet mon ancien coach
finalement j'étais j'ai passé je connais
pas la station oui mais
mais ça arrive ça arrive souvent quand
même d'aider des relations avec des
coachs qui sont qui sont malsaines ce
petit pissos on est dans un milieu du
sport vu que c'est au nom des
performances encore une fois les
affaires qu'on qu'on accepte qu'ils sont
pas acceptables mais je me rappelle
puis survient parce qu'ils te dirai qui
me prend trop de dire que j'étais rendu
assez vieux pour moi comme ça a été le
le souhaitent chose que j'ai fait et je
ne laisserai plus est arrivé puis on
était en camp d'entraînement pis je me
rappelle avoir été assez vieux pour me
faire servir de la salade sans
vinaigrette obligatoire puis là d'avoir
fait ça c'est sûr que ça aurait pu c'est
sûr que ça m'a fait pitié
c'est tellement absurde comme un boss ça
discrédite est tout le chemin qui avait
amené vers la décision de servir ce que
j'ai fais ok mais la valeur de l'opinion
comme komba lancèrent vaut plus rien
parce que si c'est tellement ridicule tu
es que le steak hommes c'est pour nom la
performance que je mange de la salade un
qu'un entraînement plus important que
les parents ils comprennent qu'ils ont
leur place de dire je vais assez à un
entraînement poser question comment ça
se passe amener certaines peut-être
situation me dire comment tu réagirais
si mon enfant tu fais telle ou telle
chose outil vraiment posé plus de
questions on se dit au sun adultes pour
leur fait confiance mais justement ça
rit trouve souvent classés s'est
prononcée clairement l'autorité ultime
après on fait que nous ayons le duo
cissé sont ces dix mains avec leurs
propres croyances la têt aussi peuvent
dessin c'est pas nécessairement méchant
ce n'est pas nécessairement mal
intentionnés il y en a que je ne sais
pas c'est pas pour me faire il y en ait
beaucoup ça reflète leur propre
leur propre croyance qui attitude qui
ont maintenant vers le poids quotidien
qui ont même envahi heureux lorsque on
est toutes danses comme je dis on met
tout dans le même monde on fait tout
avec ti avec toutes ces listes des
croyances qui circulent mettez c'est
super important donc en tant
qu'intervenant de près n'importe quel
groupe georges tu te questionner par
rapport à inquiéter c'est pas ma propre
relation entretient avec la nature avec
l'activité physique comment est ce que
ça pourrait tenter les relations entre
les interventions que j'ai avec les
jeunes qui occupaient prendre
connaissance de refus de réévaluer puis
comme tout le monde et de s'éduquer de
voir comment on peut changer si on voit
qu'il ya une lacune en quelques torts
c'est l'importance de encore une fois de
commenter autrement de valoriser les
athlètes pour tous que leur corps leur
permettant que d'un point de vue de
performance miser sur tous les autres
facteurs qui ont une influence que ce
soit de mise et plus aurait améliorer
son endurance sa force sa flexibilité ta
stratégie et ce changement la maîtrise
stratégique de 6,6 et là dessus le conte
vaut miser parce que comme je dis le
poids ccc paul seul facteur qui sait pas
lui sur le canal est un plein contrôle
mais souvent quand on va voir le poids
des points comportement fait quand il va
essayer d'aller même des choses en place
- ou si ça peut être facilement déraper
pour trouver des moyens pour propos pour
y arriver à à ce donc
donc c'est ça c'est vraiment super
gisements importants comme coach de
réaliser ça parce que 10 c'est démontrer
que c'est on voit qui est-il
c'est la personne qui dans le milieu de
vie le plus grimpé de plus d'un par an
tandis que les pas remplies père ou cité
dans l'environnement plus périphériques
mais
l'environnement sportif acuité les
parents ont un rôle les intervenants
c'est pas de se sentir non plus une
tâche
ces 4 tab archos fait sentir comme s'ils
devaient pas faire intervenir si j'ai
mon oiseau aussi way convient de
maintenant avec les pilotes d'enfants
c'est quoi maintenant parvenir ici et
qu'elle se fait cette semaine mais dans
le monde qu'ils aient stratégie qui
consomment de la campagne et tout vu la
vidéo en bas c'est vraiment l'fun de
l'engin vous êtes là vous allez
découvrir
on va mettre reliant passable dans le
dans la déception pour tout le monde
vers ce casting de cinq personnes
inclure un écran kim pour représenter
thermostat d'un important d'aller
représenter 4 personnes
on ne peut pas à travers quatre
personnes le spectre complet
relativement peu mais on a essayé je
demande à voir
d'avoir tout d'inclure le plus de formes
corporelles possible de aussi
représentés du sport qui était pas
stéréotypé d'emblée c'est d'avoir vrai
on a une jeune skateur dont un homme
plus angers qui fait du gore et affectif
d'aller chercher des athlètes aussi est
juste des sportifs des gentils des
personnes actifs
c'est en général pour représenter mais
qu'on a comme et fait un projet photo
avec l'électro non way qui a gelé ça
fait trois fois j'en passe le package
flex connaît le messie pasquet timba
nous on en mangeait avec mes est un
petit peu plus que moins félix mais
l'oeil est devenu comme le photographe
le plus en vue purement au québec c'est
des belles c'est lui qui travaille avec
correa sq fou qui s'ouvre c'est lui qui
fait martin petit çà çà çà çà fait je
fais tout les projets vraiment sympa
vraiment vraiment rageant de voir l'as
lattes artistes
j'avais écrit ce qui est écrit en
barquette yeux de tellement été généreux
pour aurait pour ce projet là il y avait
envie de s'investir et trouve est
vraiment important donc on a fait un
super beau projet photo avec lui fait
que dès que des sorties et ça vaut
beaucoup vous tirer les prix sur les
réseaux sociaux on a fait avec le même
casting du projet photo avec avec kim un
peu sous forme de documents ce week-end
à travers la capture vidéo
on a aussi des débats des colorations
comme ce qu'on a avec vous il ya moi ce
que j'ai fait avec leveaux minute qui va
sortir aussi on une balade au avec
qu'elle organise parra est d'aussi qui
qui va sortir qu'on a plein de petites
choses comme ça on est aussi là on est
qu'il est bon s'étendre sur twitter
comme pour cette cause là ont voté les
antennes ce défi tictoc avec gm pour
convoquer les jeunes enfants que je te
reprendre la vidéo cadence pour guy
lacombe ne sait aussi à la frontière et
non pas
en plus ce que je comprends c'est comme
on dit au coach m'a coûté au moins qui
réagit à trois fois beaucoup plus loin
non il ya ça il ya ce qui se passe ici
dans le fond on va être de lui ça va
être lancée puis on va sûrement beaucoup
de choses aussi pendant cette semaine de
nouveaux jeux de cercle en ligne sur le
site web
oui oui est inquiet on peut avec les
processeurs pour remettre peut-être
passer le message avec vos commentaires
à quelqu'un par exemple si vous écoutez
sur votre wii envoyé un commentaire qui
pousse le physique de quelqu'un qui aime
pas
merci infiniment